there's no time
[Music]
the time is 13. o'clock
[Music]
hey you guys
it's wednesday we're doing the main ass
[ __ ] look at the [ __ ] i did
look at me like look at i had this
little bit of skin like hanging off on
the side of my fingernail and i was like
oh i'll get rid of that and i'm like
whoop and then like i pulled a big long
thing off of it and now it's bleeding
great
go me
i hate when that happens all right i had
to go out i had to step outside the
window today and walk across the roof
and clean all the windows from the
outside is that what all that noise was
yeah did it whether it had to do it with
it you didn't tell me that you were
doing that so it's like all i heard was
like what's like what the [ __ ] is he
doing out there i kept hearing
yeah man [ __ ] outer windows i tried
to just wash them with regular windex
but then there's like some drips going
down and it was some kind of glue
so i had to get a razor blade and scrape
it i got it all off now look out the
window it's [ __ ] beautiful see a
panoramic view of the [ __ ] beautiful
neighborhood
that's right thank you for me i took the
damn i took the other screens out too
because we never use the screens the
screens just looked ugly as i got them
over here just remember don't open the
windows because i don't want pookie
being like hey i can go outside and like
climb up you can grab a screen though
and just put it in the window
that's right there next to the
witch college
cheryl says loves the love the blue
thank you
yeah i wore this for the uh recording
that we did earlier too it's like but i
can't wear i can only wear it for like a
couple hours at a time
it's heavy and it's like uh and it gives
me a headache yeah
i put on the pretty hair well i didn't
feel like washing my hair today yeah
because my hair is a pain in the ass
like to wash yeah for some reason i wash
my hair every day it's only that long
you don't have any hair yes like that's
the point that i mean when i had hair i
washed it [ __ ] two three times your
hair is like super short
and out of the shower i take three
showers a day
but i mean but that's the point that i'm
making
yeah it's easier for a guy like my hair
is like super fine so when i wash it it
takes forever to dry and then when it
does dry it like foofs out and i can't
get it to it's just it's either like
super fly away or super greasy there's
like no in between
so a lot of florida man you better
[ __ ] take three showers i mean you
kind of have to when you shower when you
wake up
you shower when you get done with work
and then you shower before you [ __ ]
get in bed
man this is that's really bleeding look
at that yeah maybe something yeah give
me a band-aid or
something
i'm all
[Laughter]
man we're like less than five minutes
into the show when we already have a
medical emergency
[Laughter]
cheryl says i would take three showers a
day in florida too yeah basically well i
do two i do one in the morning
usually what i do is i get up i do some
work um you know just whatever [ __ ]
i have to do like for an hour or two and
then i do my workout like i'll do my
bike and stuff
and then you know i'll be super sweaty
so then i take a shower and then i'll
take a shower
at night like when i'm done with work
like about
six or seven o'clock in the evening you
know what i mean and then so i so then i
can like settle down in bed and watch
movies and i'm clean you know what i'm
saying
in the summer
you kind of need more than that but yeah
man this is
this is no joke i could bleed to death
right here
from a [ __ ]
it was just you know it was just like
hey there was a little tag of skin
hanging i'm like oh let's get rid of
that and then i was like oh no
and then it just starts like spewing
blood everywhere no you got
two to choose from oh thank you i gotta
turn i think i need the big one i gotta
turn the xbox off i forgot oh yeah you
do yeah sorry this is like technical
difficulties what else is new oh my god
these these band-aids are hilarious you
guys if i can actually get this open
these came in we bought one of those big
like uh
pre-made like first aid kits it's just
like that big plastic box that has like
40 bajillion things in it like burn
cream and whatnot and the the
band-aids that we're in okay [ __ ] it i'm
just like tearing this the band-aids
that were in this
this [ __ ] must have been from the like
the [ __ ] 90s have we had this since
the 90s
why can't i open this why am i [ __ ]
i don't understand i can't open it low
intelligence
oh you know that's not the case
just my hands don't work right okay
grampa's hammer says bauhaus is on tour
for the first time in 20 years okay here
here okay i wanted to show everybody
look this band-aid says
fail yeah
i don't know why it's so random they
just came in like a first aid kit i was
like okay that's a little judgy but all
right
yeah i got like blood all over my
[ __ ] thing gross gross
okay it's fine
everything's fine that was the first aid
kit that was at the barn
oh okay so it very well could be from
the 90s yeah
i feel like that's like some 90s [ __ ]
they would do like giving you that would
have been
a black thing well okay then 2 000
sometimes 2006 2007
uh so bauhaus on tour how do we feel
about that i saw them on the gotham tour
which was a million years ago now right
um and actually that that was a really
good tour did they tour again after that
didn't they tour like 2004 or some [ __ ]
i think yeah i saw him live yeah i saw
him a few times in 2004 i saw him in
98
yeah
yeah that's what i'm saying the gotham
tour was 98 i think i saw him on that
tour and then i think they toured again
in 2000 i want to say it was 2004.
maybe i'm high and i'm not like not
remembering it right but i'm pretty sure
i saw them two times i wouldn't be too
excited to see
them
because i mean because of murphy he's
[ __ ] up
maybe he's cleaned himself up i haven't
kept track
i seen him he's not saying i'm not
saying that
um cheryl says i need those band-aids i
mean like i said this is a little judgy
but they are kind of funny
uh and cheryl yeah cheryl says tom
that's not nice he's never nice
it's just supposed to be truthful
so you think i was stupid no no i was
just playing yeah okay oh so you're
trying to be truthful but you're just
playing no i thought you're talking
about i thought you talked about um
peter murphy no that's we're going back
to what you were saying before about me
being like low intelligence
because i couldn't open that i was just
using paper
well because my fingernails are short
too
cheryl says i shower every day just cuz
but only wash my hair twice a week or
else my color doesn't last yeah you
really can't and honestly
you're not really supposed to i mean i
grew up thinking like you had to wash
your hair every goddamn day
um you don't actually it's it's actually
like kind of bad for your hair to wash
it every day because it strips out all
the moisture
and so it'll dry your hair all out and
make it all brittle
so i usually wash it i wash it two or
three times a week
um when it was red i usually only washed
it once a week and then i had to uh comb
dye through it because otherwise it
would fade to pink like immediately
so there's that went to high school with
this girl from argentina who thought
that it was bad to wash your hair so she
never washed it she was gorgeous but she
just had this [ __ ] greasy ass [ __ ]
matted hair
it's not bad to wash your hair it's
never washed it's just you shouldn't
wash it every day because it will strip
all the moisture out yeah i'm not sure
that girl bathed
well that's a whole lot she was good
looking too
good looking yeah but i don't think she
ever paid
okay
what'd she do just like scrape
everything out like the romans or
whatever the girl was [ __ ] had to
lock her next to her said boy it's hard
having to lock her next to her and this
is why she goes she stinks and i was
like really i was like yeah and she's
like yeah
hot but stinky yeah she was like uh
[Laughter]
she looked like a model she had i bet
there's a porno series she had real rich
parents and you know like the mom was
super model type and the dude was
[ __ ] like fifth generation [ __ ]
you know fourth or fifth generation
argentine [ __ ]
multi billionaire you know that i was
going to high school with i went to a
high school called the skoda graduated
sao paulo it was the [ __ ]
in sao paulo brazil it was the
it was the most expensive school there
it had private security you can look it
up online it was like the
the children of all the [ __ ]
political
people the presidents and everything of
brazil all went there all the drug
cartel families went there
amazing parties is just
underground shooting ranges private
[ __ ] armies
it was
saudi arabian level [ __ ] wealth they
were all basically robber barons
and they were all the same no matter
what side of the law they were on they
were all the same
i thought that south america was very
different and then as the internet
showed me that no america's the same way
it's exactly the same way our ruling
class is just like that
cheryl says last time i saw peter murphy
he was very fat
huge gut i haven't seen him in a long
time so i wouldn't know yeah but he was
so he was like a real finn back in the
old days
i can't i i mean i i've seen him live
like a few times where he had a little
bit of a punch but he was still pretty
skinny
but i haven't seen him a long time
and uh cheryl also said dry shampoo is
my best friend yeah dry shampoo is like
a pretty a great invention so you don't
have to like wash your damn hair every
day and just kind of like
put it in there it's all nice but you
know
grandpa just tell me we need to uh do a
trip to detroit we could do a road show
he can show us around
me and me me and him can show you all
downtown detroit but i looked online
graham most of the detroit i remember is
gone now
most of it's been torn down
these live right off uh cass corridor
second west hancock
is the wellesley the wellesley is still
there wellesley's like a nice apartments
now
it was okay when i was there but around
it was [ __ ] the apocalypse
but it's all gone they tore a lot of it
down
abandoned neighborhoods and stuff brown
stones sometimes i'm out of the damn
omega man well i imagine they just tore
out most of the stuff and then the stuff
that was left is kind of like well the
population declined and nobody lived in
that [ __ ] and [ __ ] they're not gonna
let us just sit there and
become infested with rats and
just you know what i mean dead bodies
they just find dead bodies in them you
know where they [ __ ] raped and
murdered some woman or something she'd
just be laying up there dead dead
crackheads
[ __ ]
up inside the
whole abandoned
neighborhood so they they had to do
something with them so now they're just
empty fields you know returned to the
nature a lot of the a lot of the
neighborhoods around there
dead crackheads is the name of my new
punk band dead crackheads yeah
zack says it sucks what happened to to
detroit uh i used to be an architecture
nerd and i say detroit has some of the
best in the country yeah yeah
some of the beautiful buildings
you just can't
you can't heat it anymore though some of
them
i think some of the bigger businesses
bought them but they're kind of just
like a relics
i think they turned some of them into
libraries and stuff or places where they
show off
car designs
but
you know you just can't justify a
[ __ ] 20 or 30 story
1930s or 1940s skyscraper you know 1920s
skyscrapers
just you just can't justify the
population isn't dense enough yeah i
mean the world has changed yeah since
that time no city has lasted long just
look at history none of them have lost
it along they've all moved they've all
fallen
even rome kind of became a backwater for
a while that city and became ruins and
then
ghetto and then it was built over many
times it's not the same rome
you know but trade routes change
economies and technologies change all
cities have a life expectancy
oh okay i just i thought you were going
to say something else
no that's have a life expectancy
all right so uh show we're doing tonight
after we get a little bit liquored up
and warmed up
we're gonna do we were inspired by
the phantom of the opera show that we
did
which
was actually one of the most fun shows
we did i thought i thought that came out
really well and i got like a lot of
messages saying that that was a really
great show and i got really interested
in it and somebody i think it might have
been was it rebecca i feel like it was
maybe rebecca or maybe it was tammy
tammy and she said oh you should do a
show about grimm's fairy tales or like
real stories by grimm's fairy tales and
i thought that was a great idea so i put
that in the patreon poll and that was
the one that won uh quite handily so
i had okay i know tom's gonna like look
askance at me and raise an eyebrow
initially
i had
seven
fairy tales
yeah
yeah and and i was thinking that today i
was like okay i'm gonna go through these
notes and i'm gonna winnow out because i
had some stuff and i and i thought that
i would keep to like the four that were
the most interesting maybe we could do a
volume two at some point
because initially
uh you know in addition to the four that
i'm gonna talk about
i also had snow white but then i looked
at it and i was like well that's not
quite as interesting or compelling as
the other one so i took it out then i
had little jack horner and then i was
like well that's more of a nursery rhyme
than a fairy tale even though it's kind
of interesting so i took that out and
then
i also had the pied piper which is
actually a good story but i was like i
think i'll save that for another one
um so i kind of kept with the four that
we're gonna do which i think is hansel
and gretel rapunzel
um beauty and the beast and bluebeard uh
because i know bluebeard had been asked
about specifically
so i wanted to get into uh stories
behind that as well so we're just gonna
do those four and then that way we can
like concentrate on
just those four and not worry about like
having to get through seven [ __ ]
stories so you know what i mean so
that's what we're gonna do tonight it
should be fun okay um you know i think
it'd be a good time uh also before i
forget because i did forget murder
hornets you're here yes so
look at what he sent me the other day i
got these the other day and i forgot to
show them on the show
on the matinee but then i thought well
it's good because more people can see
them anyway look look at these these are
super cool
little mexican shot glasses look at that
they're kind of more like espresso
they're probably a little espresso but
yeah you can have like little yes it
looks like a little espresso yeah a
little mesquite but make some espresso
in there yeah i have like a little
coffee maker yeah like a little touring
type that's that's what i think those
are those aren't shy glasses those are
beautiful yeah yeah shot glass doesn't
have a handle on it that's definitely an
espresso yeah an espresso mug but yeah
thank you very much those are awesome
they're glittery i don't know if you can
see it
can you see the glitter yeah you can
kind of see the glitter
i'm trying not to [ __ ] up the
[ __ ] [ __ ] up the light
zac says i forget what it's called but
one of my favorite buildings is this
bank skyscraper in detroit that's an art
deco
interpretation of a mayan temple
i don't remember that one yeah do you
know what's grand pride knows that one i
just don't remember that one i know that
sounds like there's a lot of stuff out
there graham's given statistics of how
much abandoned stuff still there i think
he said there's 80 000
abandoned homes and buildings in in
detroit still yeah there's still a lot
of them they burn a lot of them down
though tower them down
using
bulldozers amazing they just
returned they were just starting to
return it to uh to nature
there are some videos that survive to
people
taking video driving down some of the
streets some of those neighborhoods is
just every damn house has abandoned
every one of them
for like blocks and blocks and blocks
[ __ ] roofs [ __ ] caving in things
[ __ ] just you know it's amazing
everybody moved away
property's not worth [ __ ] nothing and at
least in those areas there's no jobs
you know there's no jobs
no jobs in that area
yeah i mean what are you gonna do like i
said you can't expect people like hang
out there and the auto industry is
nowhere near what it was and just the
steel mills and all that shit's gone
it's a rust belt
it won't come back
probably not although
who knows who knows what could happen
it was partly strategic a lot of it had
to do with the great lakes it was the
early 1900s it was built there
in a time when technologically that was
the select place to have it
and but not anymore if you were to build
a if you were to build a
a car factory here in the united states
a big one it would be in probably texas
because that's near mexico
there's a lot of ford stuff across the
border but b in the south
saturn was here for a while
but
it's too cold up there and it's just
it's not necessary they build it in the
south where it was hot where it was
warmer and the
population density wasn't as much so you
and you'd wouldn't have to worry about a
population that has
long history of joining unions because
unionized labor is not really a thing
here
um
up north it is so you know the unions
really kind of helped destroy that
industry they just
the unions and the factories got in on
it it was just like organized crime and
the
labor costs just went up so high the
[ __ ] people were like ah we're gonna
move to china
you know so we can make some money it's
just
the south day i think saturn i don't
think it ever was unionized they just
paid him a decent wage and they did the
job
slasher fred says if you guys ever see
that movie tomcats the scene where the
librarian dominatrix lures michael into
a trap is a reverse version of little
red riding hood um like i said i kind of
feel like i got
again i got so into this topic that
this is a topic that probably needs like
a couple of
you know like a sequel because i was
like well i can't cover
all the stuff and like i said some of
this stuff was like a little more
tenuous
but i did kind of stick with ones that i
thought were more interesting that were
actually sort of
based on an actual thing or actual like
events that happened or based on an
actual person so there's that
um guy says the vw auto automobile plan
is in chat tennessee yeah i know a lot
of stuff's here in the south i mean we
people think of the south like it was in
the 80s man we got [ __ ] eight space
programs here
[ __ ] south is not like it was it's
it's not like when i was a kid
and i've been all over the united states
and the world
it's [ __ ]
it's nice you know even the poor areas
are nice
mississippi's fun kinda especially on
the [ __ ] gulf coast man all those
casinos
we have friends that left here to go
there
we have um we actually did
a little bit of a vlog situation
yeah when we went to
uh oh yeah what the hell is that is it
loaded up
uh it is but i don't know if i want to
show maybe we'll show it toward the end
because it's kind of long
because i mean we just we went to this
new restaurant that we heard about he
heard about the biker bar this place
called the oyster trough yeah they told
me to go t-r-o-f-f that's a draw because
i said man i want some seafood where's
the best seafood man it's at the trough
there's a trough yeah you're going to
have to trouble with the trough
you know never been there man [ __ ]
oyster truck was so yeah a couple days
ago we went down there and it was it was
really good it's real good it doesn't
look like much
but the food was like amazing yeah
everything you buy the oysters and
everything and certain fish that they
offer it's by market price
so you don't know what the price is
everything tasted like super super it's
all super fresh yeah i got the seafood
platter i i'll show it to you that
[ __ ] was that big
big old
white fish like you know it's just like
fish and chips i couldn't have eaten
like a third of that yeah it looks good
though
maybe like 10 jalapeno hush puppies half
a dozen oysters they were like that big
half a dozen big old fried shrimp
there's clam strips clam strips all on
it coleslaw coleslaw homemade tartar
sauce big ol squeeze bottles of [ __ ]
homemade cocktail sauce it was [ __ ]
good it was 26 bucks for my plate
jenny's was she had what'd you have you
had the coconut shrimp i had coconut
shrimp coconut shrimp and parsley
potatoes and
bacon fried green beans yes
and she was dipping the coconut um
shrimp in orange marmalade yeah man it
was good i tried one yeah we traded off
like he gave me one of those fried
oysters and i gave him one of my legs
i'm going to get some more oysters yeah
we're good yeah we might have to go this
weekend we can we can do it i mean
it's really good but yeah we made a vlog
while we were in there and then that's
only a couple minutes but then we made a
vlog we were driving back from the
restaurant to our house
because we thought
because tom was like well maybe people
want to see like what it looks like
around where our house is yeah it looks
like a road and a bunch of like grass
and farms yeah farms
but yeah you know so we're like talking
all the way back to the house so i have
it loaded up like i don't know i'll do
i'll put it toward the end i guess or at
least
15 minutes yeah well yeah it's like 10
or 11 minutes something like that but
it's like um
we can either do it when somebody wants
to take a bathroom break or we can save
it for
side tracks or we can do whatever
because like i said i don't want to go
like two [ __ ] we'll do it about
halfway through yeah maybe like
through a break
yeah because it's probably about what 15
minutes
15 minutes what i just said i just said
it was like 11 minutes
like 11 maybe 12 minutes on the outside
when the hell are bacon fried green
beans i don't even know if they were
fried they were just they seemed like
they were sauteed the green beans and
then they had like little bitty like cut
up pieces not bacon bits
it was actual bacon but like cut up in
little pieces and it kind of came
together it was really good we got there
early it opened at three in the
afternoon and we got there like a little
bit past three so there was hardly
anybody in there there was just like a
couple hardcore people over by the bar
like drinking
so i was like i salute your commitment
bikers
the bikers show up so i've recorded that
they had some nice bikes i got a video
of that we went like on a weekday i
think it was like a monday or yeah we
went monday right monday three monday
around three three o'clock in the
afternoon
i think it was monday so nobody was
there but us yeah and they were [ __ ]
blasting heavy metal out of the damn
kitchen you can hear the chef back there
remember he's blessing that heavy metal
music well see i don't know because we
went in there like i noticed when we
first went in
the sign said that they were hiring a
cook
and then the the woman that was our
server yeah the racist she she came up
yeah when when she came out she brought
the food and like we ate some of it she
came by and she's like oh is everything
good we're like yeah man everything's
amazing because it was all really good
yeah she's like oh thank god because i
cooked it yeah she cooked it so i guess
that they're looking for a cook and so
she was filling in yeah it's easy though
it was all deep fried yeah well my stuff
wasn't i mean my shrimp was deep fried
but the other stuff okay yeah that [ __ ]
was probably pre-made and steamed
tablespoons yeah
back there cheryl says i forgot this
show makes you fat it does yeah this
sugar makes fat
[Laughter]
but it's easy it's easy to it's easy to
deep fry
seafood as soon as it starts floating
and you flip it over one time then it's
done you can tell by how high and how
high in the oil it's riding
well yeah i know but i mean the thing
about it though is that i mean i had the
the shrimp and then you had
you gave me one of your oysters yeah i
got the flat and i have to say that like
everything you bit into it and it was
like super hot and it was like it tasted
like it just came out of the ocean yeah
you know what i mean it was like it
seriously it was like really really good
yeah and like i said the place doesn't
look like anything which you can see it
in the video we filmed like the outside
of it too but platter for two platter
for two is 50. i think was it 44.99 or i
think it was 49.99 or something like
that but like you said you got the one
that was like 26 for one person and that
was like i could have got three males
out of that that was massive oh yeah it
was huge and that's the thing like i
love fried seafood but i can't eat
that's why i got coconut shrimp i said
well get coconut shrimp but i have to
get two sides that are not fried because
if i eat too much fried food i will
throw up they had all-you-can-eat stuff
too there yeah but it wasn't written
down but they said sometimes that's all
you can eat depending on what they have
like all you can eat fish
they just you know bring you three
pieces and then they just keep bringing
one piece after another after another
with all you can eat french fries they
say you you know you're not really going
to be able to eat more than you'd
normally be able to eat anyway so it's
you know see and that's kind of what
annoys me about like i love going to koi
won for example
but you know it's all you can eat and
it's like i really can't eat that much
in one sitting without feeling like i'm
in a hurl
and so
i always kind of feel like as i try to
like mitigate it like i try to not eat
anything that's fried and i try to like
not eat any anything carby
um but still like i eat like a plate and
then i get like halfway through the next
one and i'm just like oh i can't eat
anymore so it almost kind of seems like
um not worth it
cam guys are brazilian living in miami
oh [ __ ]
wait camp guy is a brazilian
or are we talking about something i
think he said he's okay and living in my
oh all right
yeah
zach says i wonder if there's a way to
make friend food i guess even at fried
food but it says friend food that's
actually healthy
no that dj maybe i said stop trying to
eat your friends
air frying will help a little bit
uh but the problem is is that people
think that fried food that the problem
is is the oil
not really the problem is all the damn
batter that's part of it uh it's it's
flour with eggs and milk
so that that adds a lot of
carb
a lot of carbs and a lot of
calories to it
um
depending on what kind of oil you're
your frying in
and what type it is that that may not be
that bad for you the the key
the key reason why a lot of southerners
had [ __ ] cholesterol and heart
problems
is because they ate a lot of bacon
grease and a lot of deep fried foods
from a very early age and lots of it
in moderation it's not that bad and even
honestly even in the southern diet
particularly when i was growing up even
if you ate vegetables
they always were cooked in like bacon
grease grease and lard stuff and lard
and stuff like that but which you know
to be fair does make them taste better
but
um
you know it's like look vegetables it's
good for you yeah well it was until you
fried it in bacon grease southerners
everybody is real big into [ __ ] pot
liquor and drippings and stuff
so yeah you have all this stuff coming
off the vegetables and it all goes
inside the rice
and you're you're gonna you're eating
every bit of the fat that every that was
put on that plate
whether you were supposed to or not yeah
because one thing runs into another oh
that tastes good then you probably put
butter on it too
yeah that's a they just keep compounding
yeah
like i said it tastes good but you're
just adding calories on top of calories
on top of calories you can eat like that
every now and then it's not gonna kill
you but eating like that every day three
times a day for years and years yeah and
like some southerners eat like that
three times not so much nowadays i feel
like yeah but back when we were growing
up it was yeah um
yes you'd have like a big fatty
breakfast like you'd fry some eggs and
bacon grease you'd have bacon with it
you'd have hashbrowns
and butter and it's in the oil from from
the from the bacon drippings you poured
that and the the bacon drips weren't
wasted that got poured into the grits
you ate every bit of those [ __ ]
fats that came off of whatever you
cooked you ate all of it and then you
saved it always in a pot so there's
always some there's always some
damn
bacon grease in a [ __ ] jar with a lid
on it next to the dab
oven next to the stove top
so you might add some more
you know
white to the to the dish you know it's
it was it was insane looking back on it
and uh but that's the way it was every
summer [ __ ] me going to mississippi
as a kid to go hang out with my dad
that's just that's just how it was i ate
like that [ __ ] three times a day
that's why my dad's got [ __ ] what
triple bypass surgery
and he's on his head
but they were giving him [ __ ] bacon
grease in his [ __ ] bottle from birth
they used to do that put it right in the
damn bottle
shake it up that was my that was like my
grandparents yeah making healthy age but
yeah
[ __ ] rat your teeth out and brought
the little [ __ ] baby teeth out
yeah from with the bottle but like i
said i kind of feel like they thought
that anything that was like
food anything that was calories was good
that was like building you up yeah fat
eating fat eating fat was good yeah
and if it was pork even better
yeah pork yeah yeah they didn't they
didn't know anybody look at the strength
of that pig
you can inherit the soul of that pig
well that's yeah that's kind of the
thing too and like they didn't
if you well and if you didn't eat enough
or if you were too
thin or you looked normal then they
thought something was the matter with
you or you were sick it's like what you
have you didn't get seconds what's the
are you are you all right yeah you know
what i mean
and
it was kind of effective
in teenagers southern teenagers were
good looking they had [ __ ] you know
some of the stereotypes of these farm
girls running around
[ __ ] full figured in [ __ ] 13 14 15
and knocked up by the time they were 14
yeah and maybe the diet had something to
do with it
but well probably two kids later by the
time 21 [ __ ] had rolled around in
that diet you know they were [ __ ]
awful health hefty well because i'm
gonna say like i'm not gonna say who
this is but i have a uh
sort of a relative
and she had a kid
and the kid i mean she was very very
heavy and then she had a kid and the kid
was
pretty much like pretty hefty like from
a very young age
and the girl started she started having
her period when she was eight or nine
yeah because her body like actually
thought that she was because she weighed
so much yeah that she was older but she
was older than she was yeah and um as
far as i know that's like fairly common
in that sort of yeah so your body will
like mistake well it's like oh well this
kid must be 12 13 years old yeah because
they weigh you know 130 140 pounds
already even though they're only like
eight or nine years old so yeah so early
onset uh menstruation that happens a lot
too like yeah
and probably like all the hormones and
stuff like that it doesn't help like
that sent all the food like milk and
stuff yeah and contrary to what people
up north think is the south was [ __ ]
highly sexually charged always
um
[ __ ] it was [ __ ] wild yeah there
was church and [ __ ] going on that was
for the middle class people
[ __ ] out on the out in those [ __ ]
um
uh uh subsistence farmers
in those uh what did you call
the houses with the shotgun shacks and
the [ __ ]
farms behind them what do they call it
what do they call them
that's
this is farming is the the the is the is
the proper name but what was the [ __ ]
southern name for it i forgot let's go
yeah this is par family was one of it
you know sharecroppers sharecropping
those sharecroppers were [ __ ]
sharecropper girls were pregnant by 13
or 14. they were just [ __ ] kids
running everywhere [ __ ] teenagers
running everywhere [ __ ] well it's not
like that anything better they had
anything to do you know
i can't blame them too much
yeah
and everybody's good looking they're
pretty good-looking evidently according
to the photos
but they didn't live long and that was
[ __ ] i don't got killed too
i mean once you get into
i mean yeah you can get away with eating
a diet like that until you're maybe in
your 20s maybe when you're pushing 30
but you start pushing 30
your body's gonna be like yeah let's
let's cut that back on i'll tell you the
same things just like down in mexico and
central america they'll [ __ ] look
great until they're about 20 something
but they've already had kids by then and
it's the diet mexican diets also real
[ __ ] real heavy and [ __ ] corn and
oils and stuff and your body can only
hold out to that
for so long you know before you start
getting real big around the middle i
mean it's good in the short term
probably right but you can't sustain
that no
not unless you're [ __ ] running
[ __ ] 10 miles a day and [ __ ]
working out like crazy and [ __ ]
probably on [ __ ] steroids then you'd
get [ __ ] huge
muscular but not a normal person just
trying to live a normal life
it's just too much goddamn fat too much
carbohydrate
yeah it's just
people really weren't meant to like eat
that much but the poor people up here in
the new world they're not starving
they've got plenty
they're growing themselves trading it
going to the fader and trading with the
open markets
slash a friend says if you guys ever
watched that series grim in the
beginning of each episode it had many
story quotes from the opening of each
episode i've never actually watched that
and i feel like i should because that
sounds like something that i would like
um so i will have to add that to my list
of stuff that i really need to watch
camp guy says soldier autopsies and the
korean war showed arteriosclerosis in a
lot of young men yeah
i mean that's kind of like
all just from their diets and stuff like
that their uh cholesterol and [ __ ] like
that was all like backed up in their
[ __ ] arteries
get all the plaque in the arteries man
do you talk about korean soldiers or
american soldiers in korea well during
the korean war so i'm assuming that it
means american soldiers during the
korean war i'm assuming i don't know if
that's true or not but
yeah
i mean people didn't know any better
like i said i've seen like a lot of
nutritional shorts from back then like
that were on mst and stuff
and yeah the stuff that they're telling
you to like eat is
pretty bad questionable yeah yeah well
it's what purina had to [ __ ] sell
that year
their food pyramid was all eat all this
[ __ ] car eat all these carbs eat all
this [ __ ] corn eat all this wheat
here you don't need that much meat just
eat a little bit of meat on top
well the top was actually like sugar and
fat sugar fat so they did actually get
that right they got that fat okay but
the bottom was carbs you were supposed
to eat like bread stuff like that which
like i said you can't like bread and
potatoes and whatnot like yeah you can
eat that but that shouldn't be the most
of what you eat you know what i mean you
got the ratios all wrong yeah the ratios
were kind of bad but like yeah it's you
know the the top of it was actually
sugar and fats which like i said so that
was correct because that should be like
the least amount of stuff that you eat
but and saturated fats but the biggest
amount at the bottom that was what i
took issue with because that was
carbs rice pasta bread i remember they
recommended you eat
more protein than say that what the
japanese and the chinese were getting at
that time you know they didn't get that
much protein
but it still wasn't that it wasn't
it wasn't that much protein when you
when you can when you compared it to how
much carbohydrate they were talking
about
it was a big difference yeah like i said
i think that was the only issue that i
really had with it was that they told
you that you should eat more carbs than
any other kind of food yeah no which is
not the case about about half and half
more or less about the same amounts of
carbs to protein about it i mean it's
good to eat like lean meat it's good to
eat like vegetables and fruits to a
lesser extent because fruits have a lot
of sugars in them as well
but
you know you can eat carbs but just not
as many as they suggest that's all i
just think it was a little bit i don't
think it was completely [ __ ] up it was
just like a little bit all right we
probably ought to get to it now we've
been on here for a while so it looks
like yeah i've showed up all right
so in case you just arrived uh this
evening show we're talking about some
real stories behind
grimm's fairy tales
which all right
so i you know i kind of feel like most
people know
about
the brothers grimm
they were two german brothers jacob and
wilhelm
and they were actually scholars
medievalists folklorists that's kind of
uh their main interest
and they were really interested in
collecting
um you know orally passed on like german
folklore stories
so what they decided to do
um because
of the uh
because this area where they were was
being overrun by the french during the
napoleonic wars
they wanted to preserve a lot of the
german stories and german folklore you
know and print them so for you for
posterity so that's basically what they
did
so they spent many years between 1812
and 1857
publishing
a bunch of different books of like
compilations of all these different
stories that they had collected they
would usually just go around to people
and like
like i said it was like oral traditions
they would go around like uh collect all
of these stories and then you know kind
of codify them in a book and uh print
them so during the years of 1812 and
1857 there were actually seven different
editions
of the book which has come to be known
as grimm's fairy tales
now even though
as most people know a lot of these fairy
tales have been adapted for children
particularly by disney
a lot of people know that the original
grimm's fairy tales were a lot more
[ __ ] up than the disney versions were
a lot like for example
uh the cinderella story which is all
kind of happy clappy like in the disney
version um in the grimm's version just
off the top of my head
you know the whole thing where
the prince like brings the little glass
slipper which i think was fur in the
original story but whatever it's a
little glass slipper and he brings it
and he's like trying it on all the
ladies
um he tries it on the feet of
cinderella's stepsisters
and it doesn't fit so they decide
they're gonna cut off
their heels and toes in order to like
cram them into the shoes
uh that didn't make it into the disney
version but that wasn't the original
version so that's just like an example
of how much darker the the original
stories were uh because the original
folklore that they collected
like i said they were mostly just
interested in preserving their cultural
oral tradition they didn't really
intend for these stories to be
for children you know necessarily they
were just stories that were going around
and they wanted to collect them so the
first edition of the uh brothers grimm's
you know collection of tales
actually looked more it didn't have any
illustrations in it it looked more like
a textbook it had footnotes and endnotes
and i had all kind of stuff it was very
scholarly looking um and it was also
like all the stories were like super
[ __ ] up
even despite that though or maybe
because of that everybody got really
into it because everybody loves a good
horror story right so everybody really
got into it um
and in the u.s alone there have actually
been over 120 different editions of
grimm's fairy tales published so
pretty successful and pretty much
everybody
probably in the western world at this
point can at least think of a handful of
stories
that they collected although as i
mentioned they just collected the
stories they didn't write them like
they'd been around for a long time they
were just like the first guys that put
them all together in one volume
so uh as i mentioned the the first
edition contains a cinderella rapunzel
which we'll talk about later
rumplestiltskin snoke snow white little
red riding hood and uh one of the most
fa and actually one of my favorite fairy
tales hansel and gretel that's the first
one we're going to talk about
um so the tale of hansel and gretel has
actually been translated into
160 languages since it was first
published back in 1812.
now i feel like most people probably
know the story of a handsome guard
there's a lot of different like
variations of it
but most people are probably familiar
but let's go over it a little bit in
case you're not
so you have a pair of kids usually a boy
and a girl
and uh their parents
usually
their dad and their stepmom although it
started out as their mom and their dad
not necessarily their stepmom and we'll
get into why that is later on so the
kids the parents aren't named but the
kids are named hansel and gretel
obviously
um the parents decide there's a famine
going on right so
they're like okay well if we die
then our kids will also die because we
don't have enough food to feed four
people like the whole family
so maybe what we should do is cut our
losses
and uh you know get rid of these kids
and then maybe we can live through this
famine and then we'll have some more
kids later on and everything will be
fine that sounds like something we do
well yeah yeah um it it's it's
cold-blooded and it's very uh you know
practical pragmatic
um but
you know it probably did happen
so they have this discussion the dad
doesn't really want to do it but the mom
slash stepmom
convinces him because he's like well
yeah that is like pretty logical
neither one of them want to actually
kill the kids outright because that
would be pretty [ __ ] up
so they're like well what we'll do is
we'll just take them out in the woods
and we'll leave them there and then let
nature take its course how about that
so okay so that's what they decide to do
unfortunately hansel the boy
has overheard them like discussing this
plan and he's like oh no that's not
gonna happen
so
he goes out and he collects all these
little bitty rocks and he puts him in
his pockets
so they take him out to the middle of
the woods being like we're just we're
going to go out here on a picnic or
whatever we're going to this but he
leaves little rocks like he leaves a
trail of rocks like all the way out to
the thing and then the parents are like
okay bye
then they leave
but because hansel was thinking ahead
and he left this trail of rocks the kids
like come back home and they're like hey
here we are you try to like leave us in
the fight
nice try yeah
so the parents are like damn
so they're like okay well next time
we're gonna search them next time
so they decide they're gonna do it again
so like okay they search all their
pockets to okay they don't have any
rocks this time
but they give them some bread
to eat
like they're just like here have this
for lunch they give them a little gila
bread or whatever and they take them out
of the woods they leave them now hansel
has been tearing off little pieces of
bread and like left the trail like he
did with the rocks but bread being
edible uh the birds come and eat it
so when hansel and gretel go and try to
go back home
all the breadcrumbs are gone so they're
like well [ __ ] now we're really [ __ ]
luckily in all of their lost wanderings
through the woods they come across
a very strange thing a gingerbread house
yeah like you do like you do
oh one of those gingerbread houses i've
heard so much about here it is in the
woods oh yeah
uh this kid that gets pretty dark
so they immediately go to this
gingerbread house and uh you know it's
usually like kind of like you know with
candy stuck all over it or whatever
that's usually how it's portrayed
nowadays and the kids are like [ __ ] yeah
so they go candy so they just go up
there and start eating the house
at which point a witch sometimes an ogre
but it's usually a witch come down it's
like why the [ __ ] you kids eating my
house
although she knows exactly why that's
why she built that [ __ ] house out
there it's a trap
he's like yeah come on she's like come
on inside i'll you know you can eat all
the candy you want
but basically this witch is like a child
eater right so
she puts a hansel in a cage
and feeds him which is like to fatten it
up because she fatten him up because
she's gonna eat him
uh she puts gretel to work like
basically as a slave right yeah
uh so
she but they have like hansel is like
pretty smart right so he
what he does is like she'll give him
food like chicken and stuff like that
and he'll keep the bones and the witch
apparently is kind of nearsighted or
can't see too good or whatever so she'll
be like i wonder if this kid's fat
enough to eat yet and she'll kind of
like pinch like his finger or something
like that see if the finger's fat but
he's like sticking the chicken bone out
there being like nope still too skinny
he can't have me yet so he's she's like
he's like putting off the inevitable um
but basically it gets to a point they
trick him and then one time like gretel
actually
uh
nuts up and ends up pushing the witch
into the oven and killing her
then they take all her [ __ ] because
apparently she has treasure also
um of course of course a witch has
treasure i mean she could just like chew
got trash
yeah why is she living in the woods in a
candy house like attracting little kids
there so she can eat them if she has all
that money i don't really know fairy
tales she's frugal
[Laughter]
why pay for it when you get it for free
i guess so because i guess that's she's
like that's why i'm rich because i don't
pay for that kind of she's a hoarder
[Laughter]
oh my god so yeah so the kids actually
they push the witch in the oven the
witch dies and so they get all her
treasure and then they go back home and
happily their mom stepmom who wanted to
leave them in the forest in the first
place is dead now that's right [ __ ] um
yeah
and their dad is like overjoyed to see
them oh my god you're still alive and
you have like a million million dollars
win win
um yeah well
the real story or like where exactly
this story came from
um
is kind of like
so it goes back to a real
famine
that took place in the baltic regions
right around uh between 1314 and 1322.
what happened was that
i think we talked about this too like
when we talked about the
you know like the land bridge and all
that kind of stuff it's if a volcano
goes off and this happened when uh when
what's that uh famous volcano uh
krakatoa no well yeah that too that
happened as well the one that buried
pompeii oh um
vesuvius there we go that's i knew i'd
think of it in a second um yeah when a
when a volcano that's large enough
uh go explodes it [ __ ] up the climate
for
a long time
um so that's pretty much what happened
here you have to hold on i'm gonna talk
about this
there was a book
that i used to have it freaked me out i
was reading it before i had that [ __ ]
ob obe it was called mysteries of the
unexplained it was a red [ __ ] book
and it was all stories that were
compiled from
um
like newspapers and [ __ ] like that from
way back and one of them was
how there's reports where
that the sky was red for a month
and that [ __ ] there were no stars for
that month and all kinds of [ __ ] like
that
it was funny because those stories
correspond
to
eruptions
yeah because they wouldn't have known
what was going on back then but that was
probably that was probably precisely
what it was options yeah and some black
options
were so bad that you'd have like four
super hard winters and no real summers
no springs
or whatever and we talked about remember
we talked about that uh the summer of
1816 which is you know lord byron and
mary shelley and stuff like that that
when they had all that horrible weather
that was why that was why that was
called the year without a summer was
because of volcanic activity yeah and it
[ __ ] up the back in those days before
any kind of modernity
no
no power production no real
understanding of [ __ ] agriculture to
the way that we understand it today
they [ __ ] would have fed huge plagues
you know i mean millions of people would
starve to death
just because some eruption
has some wild [ __ ] when you think well
that's uh that's precisely what happened
in this case makes me skeptical a lot of
what they tell us because some of those
[ __ ]
some of those [ __ ] eruptions
in just in a day put out more than
more pollutants into the into the air
than all of mankind put out in 100 years
they did it in a day
and it only took a couple years for
things to kind of go back to normal it
was catastrophic
but it gives me a lot more um
belief in the
in the earth's ability to kind of
kind of heal itself is it well it does
it's just that a lot of people are going
to suffer in the in the short term
that's kind of what people are trying to
do major risks far bigger than human
activity
massive [ __ ] super eruptions they
happen
yeah asteroid impacts
they happen
we could be sitting here cool as [ __ ]
and all of a sudden the damn asteroid
the size of a [ __ ] city hits this
place
and that's it as far as your life is
concerned i mean it does kind of have a
normal life after that no
okay uh read a book called death from
the skies yeah it's um any moment it's
written like funny but it's from a
scientific view and it's basically like
all the [ __ ] from space
that could [ __ ] up
all of our days the one that knocked out
the dinosaurs
didn't knock them out in one day like
you're thinking yeah a lot of them got
killed but they died slowly over over a
period of thousands of years because the
environment never really went back to
what it was well yeah and like you said
if you if that much [ __ ] is blowing up
into the atmosphere it's going to affect
the climate all over the globe yeah for
long for a long time
for a long time and whatever you evolved
to make a living doing as a [ __ ]
creature that job is now gone so
you had animals trying to be stuff that
they weren't
which might work
over hundreds of generations but not
thousands of generations
you know i mean it did work well like i
said if that comet hadn't hit the earth
and i think about this a lot if that if
that had if that meteor hadn't hit the
earth or that asteroid or whatever um
we would not be here no absolutely not
why not still be dinosaurs
yeah probably the dinosaurs would still
be like trucking around on earth and
there's a bunch of weird [ __ ] because
they were doing pretty good that we've
talked until that happened
another bunch of weird shits happened in
recent
well recently that we don't think of
there
there used to be a lot more ocean life
you know and and um there was more
biomass
during the uh
dinosaur period
we don't really know how big a shark can
get
we know about megalodons they were
[ __ ] huge but a modern shark might be
able to get close to that [ __ ] size
too but it might have to live for
hundreds and hundreds of years and
statistically that won't happen today
there's not enough food to feed an
animal once it gets that big out there
well and because of commercial fishing
[ __ ] like that which they didn't have
back in the old days because we've
talked about this when we talked about
like river monsters and stuff like that
and you know
go watch jeremy jeremy wade talks about
it he's like look back in the old days
when they didn't have commercial fishing
and they didn't have and there was more
food in the environment then some of
these sea creatures could get much
larger than they can nowadays not only
sea lake creeks and lake creatures too
well yeah and river creatures the
medievals did not have block and tackle
they couldn't fish like we do so they
couldn't catch a fish when it was small
on a rod and reel
mostly to catch a fish that did it with
a net and if a fish got too big you
couldn't catch it we couldn't catch it
within it so a lot of times then
sometimes they would drain a [ __ ]
pond and
according to their wood cuts
find catfish the size of [ __ ] cows
and people would go ah that's a lot
[ __ ] no that didn't happen they're
just drawing that out of scale jeremy
wade said no that could happen
well that catfish is probably two or
three hundred years old he's gone how
long do you live he's caught
some
so it's not crazy to think that like a
few hundred years ago before they had
all the technology and the commercial
fishing and everything like that that
the fish couldn't get like a couple
you know sizes larger than that that's
not crazy my uncle wilson he's dead now
he's from louisiana he said when he was
a little boy
he remembers alligator gar
being about 13 or 14 feet long they were
[ __ ] i don't know about it
he said that they had paddle boats that
would go down
in the bio with a [ __ ] front end on
them all electrified to [ __ ]
electrocute the [ __ ]
gar because people thought they were a
threat
they didn't even eat them they just
[ __ ] killed them well they don't
taste good no greasy
but they saw all those teeth and they
were so that must be dangerous so
anywhere around human habitation they
wiped out the alligator gar as it was
evidently the alligator guard used to be
[ __ ] huge
now you'd be lucky to find one nine feet
long
yeah i mean the biggest one i've ever
seen like you know snorkeling at springs
and stuff is maybe six feet about six
yeah i think i've seen a six point
and my my uncle said and he he said that
when he was a little boy
you know so that would have put it back
in the 50s probably
early 60s he said they were like 12 feet
13 feet and he said that
old-timers back then said that they used
to be even bigger
because there may have been gar out
there a couple hundred years old
back when that was you know what i mean
when there was no way to [ __ ] catch
him guard get on your line and just pull
constant
and pop your line you go what the [ __ ]
was that because it wouldn't fight like
a little fish it would just pull it was
just really stubborn you'd be like
because they weighed so much yeah they
just get hung up in the front
but you never did see them you didn't
know how big they were they probably
know they look like [ __ ] in the same
way that like they're alligators in the
same way that like barracuda look like
[ __ ] they just look mean they're not
though they're they're docile
people can get snorkeled with them
barracudas around they're just like
they'll they just get right next to them
barracudas will jump in your [ __ ]
boat yeah they catch small fish they're
not into things that are big but they
look scary and [ __ ] back in the 50s
and the 60s people were terrified of
them so they would just
have [ __ ] gar panics
and some huckster would [ __ ]
you know
make a huge [ __ ] panic and say if you
pay me money i'll go out there and i'll
wipe them all out
and they would you know there's some
electric you can google it the electric
guar killing boats
they had them
so
it's funny how
things falling from the sky
changed the world which allowed little
puny things like us to [ __ ] become
dominant well like i said we like to
think of the earth as like this big but
it's really just this tiny little ball
of rock floating in this big huge vast
ocean of
nothingness and it never stayed the same
it changed constantly throughout its
whole history and everything eventually
went extinct because it ate itself out
of house and home everything did that
everything
the only thing that remained kind of
similar was the horseshoe crab
horseshoe crab just kind of like
whatever y'all i'm just doing yeah and
it's so primitive man it's like a bug
its blood is based in copper instead of
iron it has a lot you can actually
hijack it and run it around like in some
ways that's probably like the best i
mean those types of species are the
longest
lived for sure they don't change
because they don't i mean there's
nothing about them that needs to they
have a general niche
uh they're not super complicated and
they're just like doing their [ __ ] man
and it's like [ __ ] changes they adapt
it's fine well they were also kind of
generalist they could do that that's
what i said yeah yeah it's generally
it's better to be a generalist than a lo
look at the poor little koala bear
you know
it only eats one thing the eucalyptus
so
it's kind of fate is tied to that one
tree because that's all it can eat and
it's very i mean honestly
koalas uh probably would have gone
extinct if it wasn't for human
intervention and i'm not saying humans
shouldn't have intervened because koalas
are super cute and i don't want to see
them go like extinct or anything but
because they're so their diet is so
specific their lifestyle is so specific
it's much better to be just be like
flexible flexibility is way way better
so yeah his where did we get distracted
oh bought the volcano i should have
known okay
so so there was a great famine in the
baltic regions uh between 1314 and 1322
and this was caused by volcanic activity
in new zealand and southeast asia
this volcanic activity caused uh climate
change
and that uh you know for several years
and that caused like several uh
you know a lot of starvation
and uh because crops were failing nobody
could grow any food because the weather
was all [ __ ] up
now the situation was bad in europe
particularly because they had already
been having a hard time
before the volcano happened so they
already weren't having enough food to
like feed everybody so when that came
along
it got really really [ __ ] bad
so when the great famine comes along
um
basically
they think that maybe
30 million people died in this famine
and and i think this is just in europe
25 of the population in some areas
uh starved to death because of this
now
as you might imagine in europe during
this time period because everyone was
[ __ ] starving to death
um some pretty [ __ ] up [ __ ] happened
including
some old people reportedly um
they decided they were going to allow
themselves to starve to death so that
younger people could live
which
heroes
gonna say but that's pretty [ __ ] up
um so there was a lot of uh but on the
other end of the spectrum there were a
lot of families killing their babies and
stuff like that because they said hey
free meat tammy showed up yeah i saw
that
high desert zero zero four horseshoe
crabs freaked me out when i saw when i
was five they are pretty weird looking
but
i don't know
slasher fred the opening of finding nemo
has a dark opening in which martin's
wife and all of their eggs are eaten by
barracudas leaving him a widowed father
to his only son nemo i'm getting
confused i'm getting confused now tammy
wasn't a girl from germany was she no
that's that's sandra sander haven't seen
her in a long time
yeah well the okay sandra is in germany
yeah um so it might be she might be
sleeping but she never leaves comments
sandra you better check in i don't know
yeah like are you okay did the germans
get you yeah we haven't seen her a long
time i'd like i'm not all that surprised
that she doesn't show up on live streams
because like i said especially since
we've gone like an hour or two later
tammy says his presence i think yeah
yeah that's right yeah tammy just sent
it
the card and the money instead is the
the the cookie butter which ooh that's
right i got like we got these dollar
store confused right now we got the
dollar store cookies that are like the
cheap jack oreos which i don't love
but i dipped them i dipped a couple of
them in that cookie butter and it was
delicious it's good yeah so much better
that'd be good on fruit tammy and toast
we've got a [ __ ] about a 14-minute
movie of us driving around and us going
to the [ __ ] to the oyster trough
all right the bikers said i was i asked
the bikers when i was up there at the
[ __ ] bar i was like man i want some
seafood where do you get seafood right
here go man you gotta go to the trough i
said what the oh it's the trough yeah if
i can we wouldn't check that out mad
place is [ __ ] fantastic
buying oysters
oysters by market value and certain fish
by market value and they cook it for you
just for 26 bucks i got a huge platter a
huge platter of fried fish oysters clams
shrimp hush puppies homemade [ __ ]
tartar sauce homemade cocktail sauce
french fries
jenny got [ __ ]
coconut fried shrimp it just it's
beautiful you'll see it and um it's it
was a nice place just not much to look
at i go man the place looks crazy from
the outside
you go it's a very florida looking real
florida very important
it's on the water it's on the lake
there's a lot of seafood restaurants
along that right uh stretch because
there's like a lake right there or a bay
or whatever the hell that is they don't
have to wow you with their decor they're
gonna wow you with their food it was
fresh it was good handmade
and the prices were great
26 bucks you'd get a huge platter
i mean that was like like i said three i
could barely eat it three times more
food than i could barely eat it and tom
actually
he ate most of it but even he was just
like i couldn't finish it off he
couldn't finish it i had to leave some
in french i one oyster and i think two
or three of your french fries yeah you
ate some of the of it off there and i
still could barely fit i could i
couldn't finish all that was a lot and
it's weird because i was thinking about
getting that and then i was like no
because that's going to be all fried
food and i'll just probably like eat
like a quarter of it and then what a
throw up and then they had that platter
for two that was it was nearly 50 i
think it was 50 bucks i think it was
44.99 i have to look at the menu you
guys can look online it's called the
oyster trough t-r-o-f-f yeah trough and
um what was that uh it's not useless
that's uh
i think that's still useless
is it
i guess that's still useless yeah you
can look at it you look at it from the
outside that's not really much to look
it doesn't notice it's like lime green
and [ __ ] yeah lime green
it doesn't have to look fancy
to be good well i told you in daytona
and i can't remember the name of it but
we used to have a place in daytona that
looked like nothing it looked like this
little dump it was like the end of like
a strip mall yeah
but that place had the best [ __ ]
seafood they had their own boats and
they would go out because it was
literally like less than a mile from the
atlantic ocean
and they the boat would come in i think
it had two boats the boat would come in
and they would bring the [ __ ] off the
boat and then they would cook it and
then they would serve it to you that and
it was really good that 26 [ __ ]
platter would have probably been close
to 100 or 100 in in new york no problem
no problem maybe more
that's what that would have cost in new
york
okay so where was that all right so uh
yeah 30 million people dying in the
great famine
old people
uh
choosing to starve to death to allow
younger people to continue living
although some people also decided they
were going to eat their kids because you
know babies useless mouths to feed might
as well eat them for meat
i'm not saying that i'm just saying
that's baby tammy said the hub took her
out on a motorcycle and had a mexican
for dinner oh that's good
hopefully he didn't try to run
they had mexicans for dinner
okay okay okay
[Laughter]
okay
um also there was a uh kind of a thing
that was published in 1315 in estonia
that actually said that in some cases
mothers would allow themselves i don't
know if they allowed themselves or if
they were like murdered or they like
allowed themselves to be killed and like
fed to their children so that their
children could live that's how bad this
[ __ ] was okay so nobody like complain
about [ __ ] nowadays because they can get
back yeah you don't gotta like eat your
kids or nothing
um also people were eating uh dead
people they were going to cemeteries
digging up freshly dead folks yeah bad
and eating dead people so they were
desperate is what i'm saying this kind
of [ __ ] happened in north korea
kind of what i'm trying to get across
you know what i mean hugo says cool wig
jenny thank you
yeah this is probably gonna look good
with long straight this is my probably
my favorite she looks real good in long
straight hair parted in the middle
well you know it's my actual hair i'm
just gonna try and get it back to that
but it takes a long time to take a long
time to grow hair like that it does yeah
it's it used to be like that but it
takes me a long time to like
cut it and then once it gets long i'm
just kind of like god this is so
annoying
because it well it takes so long to like
wash it and dry it and like it gets it's
not that the bangs grow out too see
that's what i'm saying i have been doing
that but the bangs take a long time to
grow out too so yeah it's a pain in the
ass
so uh so this was a real famine that
happened where people were
reportedly probably
almost definitely um
eating one another because they had to
i mean
they would die otherwise
and so that's kind of the
uh background of where the story of
hansel and gretel came from
because the thing about it okay so
there had been stories kind of similar
to the hansel and gretel story prior to
that one coming out
but
those ones didn't really have
the sort of weird like cannibalism
aspect to it i guess it's mostly kind of
about
fear of abandonment that type of thing
um so there was this
italian fairy tale that came out in the
17th century
um
from a guy named john battista bassily i
guess i'm pronouncing that
sort of correctly maybe
and
he was also a collector of fairy tales
as the brothers grimm were
now he wrote a version
in where he collected a version in which
uh there were two kids who were actually
called uh nanilo and nanella if i don't
know if i'm pronouncing that right
um same kind of thing it's the
stepmother and she like abandons the two
kids in the woods
um and it's kind of similar but it's
like not bread he like the kid like
leaves oats
as a trail and then a donkey eats them
but it's like the same kind of thing
there was also a story came from romania
from right around the same time period
called the little boy and the wicked
stepmother
um and in this one the two kids are
abandoned and find their way home
following a trail of ashes
but when they get back home this one is
a lot more [ __ ] up when they get back
home the stepmom is still alive and she
kills the little boy
and makes
the little girl
cook him
for dinner damn so you know there's that
um
the little girl and this is where it
gets weird so the little girl uh does
that because she's a kid and what else
is she gonna do but she decides she's
gonna hide the kid's heart in a tree as
you do
uh the dad doesn't know what's going on
and he actually eats his kid
without knowing what that is wow this
meat's delicious it's so succulent
this [ __ ] goes way back history well
that's what i'm saying that that's why
that's what i'm saying is like the great
famine spawned all of these
tales like of cannibalism of people like
leaving their kids in the woods because
real [ __ ] like this was actually going
on at this time it even goes back even
before that
uh
cyrus the great
came to power
because
during a revolution
that was caused
by a king
who forced his right hand man to eat his
own son as punishment for lying against
him that right hand man helped
helps the persians come to power and
overthrow that king
okay because of that
that uh his right his main vizier was
forced to eat his own child
and he didn't know it was coming he went
to a banquet and they opened it up and
there was this kid cooked
and he says you'll either [ __ ] die or
you'll [ __ ] submit to my will you
betrayed me blah blah go ahead you you
hadn't try it first and they made him
eat the sun he kept us cool about it
though
and then later he's like i'm gonna
[ __ ] help fo men a rebellion to
overthrow this [ __ ] and that's how
[ __ ] cyrus the great became
it gotten power over persia and he
didn't kill that king he made him made
him an advisor that's kind of how cyrus
later on became magnanimous he was a
magnanimous liberator
he didn't [ __ ] kill the old dictators
and evil [ __ ] that came before him he
brought them into his own service
and used them for what they were for you
know like advisory roles but of course
very pragmatic because they wouldn't
fight as hard against you if they knew
that they would live
he knew exactly what he was doing
man that [ __ ] oh that's all i was
saying about it but cannibalism goes way
back
that story if that actually happened
goes back way back into the bc period
so making people eat their own children
and cannibalism goes way way back oh
yeah it absolutely well it's kind of
like a power play it's a power thing
right i'm just saying that a lot of the
versions of hansel and gretel that we
know nowadays
um kind of came to full flower
during this particular period in the
baltic region when there was this
massive famine and it speculated that
people actually did like i said eat
their own kids yeah
old people like or eat their own parents
um you know people were eating dead
bodies [ __ ] like that that's how [ __ ]
desperate they were and that's where
this kind of uh story came from
so where was i okay so
uh the so the little girl hides the
boy's heart inside the tree like i said
the dad eats his son
not knowing about it
uh the sister won't eat anything
you know which is understandable
now
after they eat though
the little girl takes the
her brother's bones
and puts them in the tree with his heart
and somehow
magically
this makes him
turn into a cuckoo what's up tina tina
just showed up hey what's up
so she turns into a cuckoo
the bird comes out and he can talk
because of course
and he basically says hey my dad ate me
uh but hey i'm safe now my stepmother is
a [ __ ] bye that's not exactly what what
he said but that's close enough
um so the stepmother trying to
this is hilarious to me the stepmother
is trying to shut the bird up
so throws
like a lump of salt at the bird but it
bounces back and hits her in the head
and kills her damn
that was one heavy lump of salt
how big was this lump of salt that we're
talking about was it like that was it
like a softball
what i was thinking like a sugar cube
size and i was like that wouldn't kill
you but okay it's a fairy tale
um stay tuned tila we're gonna play the
movie that we recorded me and jenny
maybe i mean like
maybe do that toward the end like don't
get everybody because i'm still on the
first story okay for christ's sake we're
gonna go and we're still looking at our
dates he did
um so yeah i should mention that the
original source
for the hansel and gretel story
at least as people know it nowadays like
the version people know nowadays
came directly from a woman named
henriette dorothea wilde
now she was a woman that was
a neighbor of the brothers grimm
and they interviewed her because she had
she was older and she like knew a lot of
stories that she had gotten from her
family
and so they collected a lot of stories
from her she actually ended up marrying
one of the grim brothers wilhelm
and it speculated
that
because she was a little bit older
she might have
um
had ancestors
that
had lived through the famine
and had actually done some of the [ __ ]
because
the thing about the whole hansel and
gretel story is that they know that
people resorted to cannibalism during
the great famine right
and it could be
that
people that
resorted to that during that time period
after that time period had passed
maybe the stories evolved to make the
people that
you know ate the babies or ate the dead
bodies or whatever maybe that evolved to
make those people like witches or ogres
because made them into the bad guy even
though obviously they had in real life
had done it like through desperation
but maybe after the bad times had passed
the story evolved to
make them the villains you know what i'm
saying that's kind of like what the
speculation about it is
that
um
you know that because people were eating
babies because people were eating dead
bodies and stuff like that
you know during the time no one was
going to judge you because everyone was
doing that kind of [ __ ] because everyone
you know was tough all over
but after that had passed by and the
stories kind of evolved and like other
generations came
you know afterward and didn't hadn't
experienced it firsthand
that
maybe they started to villainize the
people that actually did that and like
cast them as
witches or ogres like in later versions
of the story it makes sense they think
that that's probably what happened in
the evolution of that particular story
because you have to think the grimms
didn't collect this story until the
1800s
um by which point this story was at
least 500 years old if not older
yeah so it's almost kind of like a
modified version of survivor's guilt
oh yeah definitely and guilty for
survival what it is is you cast guilt on
people who did survive you ate your baby
you [ __ ] witch
yeah i think that's exactly what
happened i think that's exactly what
happened like i was reading an essay
about that earlier and i was just like
that sounds
yeah i mean from a folkloric point of
view that sounds exactly like
the way that that would evolve because
if you didn't grow up
during the famine yeah if you didn't
know anyone directly if you personally
did not have to resort to those measures
then it's very easy for you to look back
from your more comfortable future
and judge the people that did that you
don't have to look that far back
eastern europe world war ii
[ __ ] poland czechoslovakia [ __ ]
places where the soviet union and the
[ __ ] not and the third reich were
fighting those people weren't getting
any food there was cannibalism going on
uh siege of stalingrad [ __ ] also
cannibal cannibalism going on
um
if you're starving to death
you might eat and may not eat your own
child but you probably might eat
somebody else's child there's all kinds
of [ __ ] that went on
and a lot of people that [ __ ] did eat
other people they ended up dying too
you put enough you put a crickets inside
a [ __ ] bait box and let them eat that
slice of potato up come back two or
three days later there's nothing but bad
ass crickets in there that's the only
survivors and they're all eating each
other
i mean you make dry animals they don't
really have any other like i said choice
you put humans in a situation where they
don't have any other choice there's no
other food right
i mean and i i feel like still we still
get a little bit judgy about look like
look what happened to
you remember that movie alive which was
based on a real thing that happened like
the
uruguayan
soccer players and like their plane
crashed in the mountains
and the chile wouldn't it um
yeah yeah somewhere around there said it
crashed and they were there for like a
while and a bunch of uh you know a bunch
of the people died like on impact
obviously but some of the people like
died later brexit conditions
and
the ones that survived they're like we
hate to have to tell you this but we had
to eat the people that died yeah here's
the thing they didn't kill anybody but
they dead passengers there'd be no
problem with that from my point of view
and i i still kind of feel like people
were like weird about it though but it's
like jesus christ like what the [ __ ]
would you do if you were in that same
situation and here's the thing i'm not
saying anybody like had a good time with
it you just do what you got to do here's
the thing that mountaintop was frozen so
all the meat was preserved
it's not like you're eating the heads
and the [ __ ]
the bodies in other words the torsos or
anything or anything that has the
identity of that person they ate the
legs
which means that the fir person could be
buried later on
you're not eating a whole body you're
not desecrating it yeah i feel like
someone would say if that person in the
spirit world would say could i have that
leg yeah take it
you're trying to live
seriously i'm just i'm telling you right
now if we were ever in a situation where
we're in a plane crash or you have to
eat me you have everything just go ahead
and eat me it's fine
it's fine you know i'm not there anymore
it's head or the face or anything like
that you're just going to take it's fine
you're just going to take the part that
has the meat on it which is the legs
really legs and booty of course booty
got meat as teeth
tila just said what would be the best
cut to eat on the other body
yeah yeah i feel like that would
probably be like the most taste the best
tasting yeah there's usually not much
because it's nice like marbled fat
there's not much meat on arms on the air
i haven't thought about this very much
to me there's all kinds of meat on the
arms but on the average person they're
going to eat on arm it's going to be the
booty legs
uh [ __ ] yeah i feel like his thighs
and butt are kind of like the main thing
maybe calf depending on the person but
that's where all the meat is and it
tastes like pork according to every
person who's said yeah who's ever eaten
it tastes like a pork
don't go for [ __ ] brain or anything
you get that damn kuru all right don't
you you don't want that any internal
organs you don't want any of that
and in a situation like it's alive where
they're up there in the damn mountains
well just alive it's alive it's the
killer baby yeah
[Laughter]
you're not you're not trying to
desecrate the human body
or this person so you want to save it
for the relatives so there's something
to bury so don't leave
leave the face and the torso and
everything alone you know [ __ ] be
respectful
you're just trying to live and that
person would totally understand it
they'd be doing the same thing
in that situation yeah i mean if the if
the conditions are that extreme yes i
really don't think anybody would bot and
honestly i would feel really bad like if
if anybody that had to resort to that
like felt bad about i'm sure they do i
would i get it but
don't i mean jesus i would just be save
my skull
you know may save my head and the skull
for the family they can bury that save
the bounce
because it's all gonna rot anyway
yeah it's all i'm not really all that
worried about to be honest i'm not
really all that worried about like what
happens to my body afterwards i'm really
not right
it's not me anymore so i don't really
care no um you know what i mean not you
anymore i mean if you got absolutely
projected permanently that's what i mean
or whatever or i'm just not there
anymore in either case it doesn't really
matter so if you got to eat my ass eat
it right
[Laughter]
somebody just your ass somebody just a
whole porn video somebody just gift that
right someone's got to eat my ass yeah
okay that's what i said that's what i
said
um right the juicy areas the juicy areas
sure
i mean you know
so like i said i would never [ __ ] i
would never judge yeah i would never
judge but apparently the hands taste
like bacon teeth do they yeah the hands
there's there's no fat on your hands
though they're salty like i mean not
really they're salty like bacon
uh that was from the uh the it's the the
alive people said that they did roast
they did cook some hands it was like
bacon
because of course somebody asked them
yeah although i'm not judging people
that ask about it either because
everybody's curious yeah
although if i was in a situation like
that where i was in a plane crash and i
had to eat my friends yeah i don't know
how happy i would be about i don't know
maybe it's me so i might be like oh let
me tell you like what human beings taste
like i might be all about that i don't
know that it might be weird though
taylor the vikings
which are me and jenny's
[ __ ] genetic ancestral overlords the
ones that [ __ ] came and enslaved us
back on the [ __ ] hockey motherland
back on the british islands when they
came in when they were [ __ ] over the
celtics and the [ __ ] anglo-saxons
they called it long pig
long pig yeah i kind of feel like
everybody's called pig yeah
right long pink long pig
it was like a pig but it was longer
[Laughter]
because
now here's the thing
vikings not all the norris were vikings
the vikings were the [ __ ] raiders
they went viking
they went raiding
uh but evidently they can't they would
they liked cannibalism and uh because
you know they just ate i enjoyed
cannibalism yeah
and they called it
not really i'm just
they come in and grab the best women and
take them back and sell them and [ __ ]
[ __ ]
take all the gold and
that was a [ __ ] interesting [ __ ]
period of time man
the viking
era but they they expanded so quickly
and they interbred with all the other
white people they vanished they made a
little empire didn't last long
and then their descendants were just
regular regular people
they're like i don't want to be like him
know
how do we be like my dad he was an
[ __ ]
most people have that
veronica left it's a hobby yeah
cannibalism um yeah
yeah laughing about the long pig
yeah so uh
as i mentioned like tila said something
earlier about like why did these stories
like um resonate with children like okay
it's really weird because the original
what tina says good salad three mating
is sad about bb all i gotta say is i
plan on carrying a bbw sauce in my purse
from now on you never know what happened
at the drop of a dime or asteroid yeah
that's right i mean you know some salt
and pepper too sister
let me go to the restaurant i mean you
know
you got to be prepared
i got to be prepared
i'm not trying to like [ __ ] it because i
know some people have had to like
actually resorts cannibalism i'm not
making fun but because that must be
[ __ ] horrible i can't imagine
but
i don't know
in a way it's like it's so absurd that
it's i don't know i always find it funny
but you know
so yeah so you were asking earlier like
the grim fairy tales
why did like chip the weird thing about
it is it seems like
everybody was really into the grimm's
fairy tales including kids even though
the original uh versions of them were
absolutely not intended for children
they were actually more like scholarly
textbook type situation
um but everybody really got into them
including kids
so uh the grimms knowing that
the later editions that they put out
they actually kind of like um softened
them up a little bit because you know
most people know that the original
versions of the grimm's fairy tales
because most people are familiar with
like the disney versions but the
original versions were a lot more [ __ ]
up
than the disney versions
um
but so i do kind of feel like they
dignified themselves once they
understood that children were
reading the [ __ ] because by the time
that that happened that they realized
that
uh they had kids of their own
so i guess they were kind of like man we
don't want our kids reading this stuff
that would be messed up so they kind of
like try to tone it down a little bit
interestingly one of the changes that
they made in as pertaining to hanseling
reddle
was that in all of the early versions of
hansel and gretel
the villain of the story
mostly was
the kid's mom their biological mom
their mom was actually the one that made
the suggestion hey
we need to leave these kids in the woods
because
her like i said her reasoning was
hey we don't have enough money or enough
food like to feed four people
um but so if we die then the kids will
die anyway so it's like we might as well
leave them out there and eat food
ourselves and then we can have more kids
later that was like her logic
now in the original version of the story
it was their actual mom
but
as it became more apparent that children
were getting into the grimm's fairy
tales the grimms actually made it their
stepmom
so it wouldn't be quite as
[ __ ] up i guess because it's not like
their biological mom so i kind of feel
like that happening was maybe where that
whole like evil stepmother
trope
sort of came from
i feel like because so many fairy tales
have that evil stepmom and maybe why i
think like a lot of the original
versions of the fairy tales
it was the actual moms but they were
just kind of like well now kids are
reading this and we don't want to think
that their actual we don't want kids
think that their actual moms are going
to eat them and [ __ ] and then that would
be messed up but it's like if it's a
stepmom then it's okay because they're
not like biologically related to you so
it's not
as
[ __ ] up but i don't know i just i
found that very very interesting when i
learned that
but you know
that they made it a stepmom instead of
the actual mom because the the original
versions of hansel and gretel were all
the kids actual mom the biological mom
but the later versions after the grimms
found out that kids were getting into
the story yeah made it the stepmom so it
was like one
so it was like one step removed
um so i guess that kids
would not be like freaked out by the
fact that their own moms might eat them
or leave them in the woods
which you know might be a little
traumatizing for children just gonna say
um but yeah all right so let's talk
about
our second
uh story
the yamazaki my mom gave me a four slice
toaster for a bath toy
oh my goodness
what are you doing oh same device okay
all right so the second one we're going
to talk about
is the story of
rapunzel
now
does everybody know the story of
rapunzel yeah yes no
uh lady locked in a tower she had super
long hair prince like climbed up it what
not we'll get into it a little bit
but uh there's a lot of different
versions of it i remember one version
that i had in a book as i was when i was
a kid but i'll get into that a little
bit later
um pretty widely believed that the real
story behind rapunzel
probably based
on the story of
saint barbara she was a very early
christian martyr
and she was also locked in a tower
um
the first version of her story was
written down in 1275
ce by an archbishop of genoa
now
it's not just the fact that she was
locked in a tower um there's a lot of
other similarities to the story i'm
pretty sure this is probably where the
original story came from although there
were some influences from some other
[ __ ]
now uh saint barbara obviously was not
locked into her
tower by a witch or an ogre or whoever
like from the original story
the person that put her in a tower at
least according to the story was her dad
so
okay so she was a christian martyr right
so you know how the story is going to go
so it's the early days of christianity
and barbara
had converted to christianity secretly
now her dad who was a quote-unquote
pagan
um
[Music]
found out that she had converted and was
pissed off about it ooh the lighting
went all weird that was weird was that
it was that light back there what
happened to it it decided to go to
another color
randomly
i don't know
it didn't touch anything no i didn't
touch anything
it does that every now and then
yeah it's there's no rhyme or reason to
it please don't try to find any rhyme or
reason to it there isn't it just does
that
so uh so yeah so he was like i'm not
having any daughter of mine be part of
this new weird christian
cult thing that we have going on
so
i'm gonna lock you in a tower
one of the main things that he was
afraid of
um he was a very uh wealthy dude a
merchant in rome
and he didn't like that the whole
early christian emphasis on helping out
the poor he's like [ __ ] that yeah
i don't
um and because he knew that his daughter
was sympathetic toward the poor
man what a terrible person she was
um because he knew that he's like yes
that sounds right up her alley so i'm
gonna need to like [ __ ] you know
sequester her away from that [ __ ]
um there was also the fact that saint
barbara was uh thought to be so
beautiful that she had just like dudes
[ __ ] stalking her and being her
suitors in quote-unquote like all the
time her dad was like sick of dealing
with it i guess
uh because most of the dudes he did not
deem like worthy of her
and he was kind of sick of dealing with
it so he said well you know what i'm
just going to like put her up in a
[ __ ] tower and that'll solve uh two
problems at once
he's like i want to be the one to pick
her husband
you know like they did back then
now interestingly though
so her dad
locks barbara in the tower
but she still
found out about christianity anyway
now one thing she was locked in this
tower she couldn't get out it was just
like this big tall tower and had a
couple windows and they would raise up
they had a basket at the bottom it was
very silence of the lambs they had a
basket at the bottom and they would put
food and clothes and whatever
she needed they put in the basket and
they'd put it up the tower just like in
the rapunzel story and they'd go that
was all the [ __ ] she needed right now
the story goes that somebody whoever it
was that was you know putting the [ __ ]
in the basket
including the lotion apparently
you know
allegedly
also pushing out
well you know that was a good one jenny
i mean it was laying right there
comedian i won't make you a comedian
damn that was [ __ ] i'm funny yeah i
know that look man look that's not not
enough light turn that light up can you
can you hit that again no you can't hit
it again it's maxed out yeah well no i
mean i can't i'm looking at myself on
that [ __ ] channel i look red
you always look right like back here
with spock and [ __ ]
okay all right well you're too far back
maybe you should scoot closer no no no
because i gotta have all my [ __ ] here my
control panels
my drinks yeah your control panel yeah
okay go ahead
so
yeah what no what i was saying is that
i'm actually funny but a lot of times
like i'll say funny [ __ ] like when we're
not on the live stream yeah and then
when we're on the live stream like he'll
he'll say it like he thought of it oh
wait hold on she's saying i was stealing
her [ __ ] that's not true that was like
you were stealing my material that's
that's true you were stealing my
material
now we'll be watching these movies
with some funny [ __ ] i'll start [ __ ]
laughs
we recorded a good one today we were
watching communion yeah community the
christopher walken one which like i said
if you're a patron it'll go up on
tomorrow and if you're not it'll go up
on friday
um
i think i made a joke about because it
was like a weird noise that i was like
are they checking his shocks and like i
don't know i busted
because i thought that i think that you
thought that i didn't know what that was
yeah
it started
it occurred to me that that's why you
thought it was funny because she's like
that you were surprised that i knew what
no
no when i heard it that it made that
amaze me it didn't phase me because to
me it was just kind of a generic
a generic [ __ ] air tool sound but
then when you say when you shut checking
the shots you're checking in it reminded
me of like because the alien air ratchet
yeah the aliens were doing like some
[ __ ] pep boys [ __ ] yeah like from pep
boys yeah like you put them up on the
lift and we're gonna like check
underneath the hood yeah they didn't do
anything high-tech they just recorded to
make that to make that sound effect they
just recorded a [ __ ] air ratchet
going
[Laughter]
i mean that's very clearly what that was
it was clearly terrestrial
i mean clearly a terrestrial i have to
say
when you guys say like we recorded like
i said earlier today
uh when we were still sober we recorded
a review for that movie
and it's
it's pretty hilarious that's just that
[ __ ] crazy that is a batch of crazy
movies yeah i give you my theories on
[ __ ] tila says communion the alien
abduction story yes yeah
yeah it's kind of like
the naked lunch of [ __ ] ufo [ __ ]
brother as i said well it is what it is
it's like naked lunch
it's something
it's something
i haven't seen in a long time yeah
you'll see christopher walken walking's
the [ __ ] out of that [ __ ] that
[ __ ] he's just walking
the walking level is [ __ ] 10.
10 out of 10.
it's one of the walkiniest christopher
walken lights i've ever seen
so this is how it's going how dare you
that he put some up his booty and he
looks he looks the alien goes how dead
don't ruin it
don't ruin it
don't write it
walking gets probed anally
i had totally forgotten
i was making a joke about it before that
happened and then i was like oh yeah i
forgot this actually happened in there
yeah [ __ ] funny as [ __ ] i mean you
know not a good movie really it's not no
it's not well made but not
boring except the parts where the crazy
shit's happening it's [ __ ]
it's seriously one of the weirdest
movies ever it's weird i hadn't seen it
before but i'd forgotten about it
completely
but yeah it's you'll see
we were it was almost an hour i think it
was 50 minutes
we were just i couldn't get over it okay
he says she likes walking yeah yeah you
don't like him in that movie
[ __ ] i tell you it's it's
almost kind of like the quintessential
christopher walken movie you get to see
every facet of his
uh let's call it an eccentricity yeah in
this and she mentions dead zone i
actually think dead zone is his best i
loved it i think that's his best
he's always going to be that dude from
the dead zone
i'm like that that's
that's really his [ __ ] role
i don't know if it was because i saw
that when i was a kid or some kind of
nostalgia but no it's still good i saw
movies yeah it's it holds up
absolutely him playing johnny is like
that's that's that dude from that book
fourth year down says never go full
walking yeah he was full walking on that
[ __ ] um in this movie yeah something
goes up in his booty go ahead and
[ __ ] see community imagine walking
getting violated
and him not being all that mad about it
but saying how dare you
don't ruin it don't do it
oh my god that movie would have scared
the [ __ ] out of me if it had come out in
81 when i was a kid
yeah i could see that i could do that
all right so where was i
um i forgot where i was okay oh we we
got distracted with the with the basket
yeah okay
that's where we went off the track
that's where we went off the rails all
right so
so yeah so they're
you know uh she's trapped in the tower
and people are putting things in the
basket for her to like you know live on
like food and whatnot so somebody
according to legend put a little bible
in there i don't even i don't know if
there's a bible yet but it was just kind
of like christian writings and there was
like hey read these
um so put them in a basket
so she read it and she was like oh yeah
this is all me and i'm into it
um she also apparently tricked her dad
into sending
a priest up there
because she pretended to be sick
and she's like oh i need like a doctor
who maybe was also a priest or something
like that and then she got like a
baptism
um so she was like
secretly practicing christianity like in
this tower
um one of the stories too was that this
the tower originally had two windows
but she when her dad was out of town
she calls the
you know i don't know the the guys that
were like working on the tower or
whatever it's like hey can you put
another window in here so it'll like
represent the trinity
um and she like said something about it
too like about how these three windows
represent the trinity at which
time like her dad was kind of like [ __ ]
you're a christian [ __ ]
uh so he got really mad
so her dad who sounds like um a little
bit of a dick have to say
so he comes back finds out about the
whole window situation finds out she's
been secretly practicing christianity
all this time even though he
specifically put her in the tower so
that that wouldn't happen
so he
dragged her by her hair
to the jail
and is like take this [ __ ]
she's a christian
i'm not having it
she put her on trial
so they put her on trial now the judge
who was also a pagan
says to her well you can renounce
christianity
or you can be tortured
and because this is a saint story and a
christian
you know saint story
obviously she's like torture me [ __ ]
uh she supposedly also made like a real
big like speech about it you know
because they always do
um
so some of the [ __ ] that she i don't
know if this actually happened or not
but um
she apparently got super super tortured
she got stripped naked she got
beat with [ __ ] leather straps and
then they put salt in the wounds
then they cut off her tits
what and yeah don't do that
i thought that would get your attention
yeah i was like wait what don't cut off
their kids
you can do you can do whatever you want
but leave the tits alone leave alone
leave the tits alone i'm gonna make you
a shirt that says leave this one
[Laughter]
um yeah so they cut off her tits
apparently
and all that's like not funny and also
like uh you know just burned her
everywhere like lamps and whatnot uh
then they also uh
you know took her through the town naked
you know to shame her
so there was that
and then her dad who like i said a
little bit of a dick
grabbed her again by her hair and cut
off her head
he beheaded her
so that's nice
now according to the legend i don't
think this really happened but according
to the story at least the story that the
christians tell because like i said this
is a saint narrative
uh as soon as
the dad had cut her head off
a bolt of lightning killed him
that sounds like christians in which
yeah in which case like barbara from the
afterlife was like could you have done
that before he cut my head off or that
would have been nice thanks but you know
that didn't happen
um now interestingly even though
obviously uh there are a lot of
parallels between the rapunzel story and
the saint barbara story
now it's never mentioned outright in the
saint barbara accounts that she has
super long hair but they do mention her
hair
on several occasions
as in
uh you know her dad
grabbed her hair like several times
during the course of the story they
didn't say it was like longer than usual
but they did like bring up her hair like
a lot of times but they're bringing the
hair up a lot of times somebody a
storyteller is gonna expound on that
yeah hair hair hair oh her hair was long
so long it went all the way down and
yeah i see where they're coming yeah so
you know that that kind of came but
i will note that there was an older
story that maybe the whole hair so long
that you could climb up it yeah trope
came from
this probably came from
uh a persian story
and i'm sure i'm pronouncing that this
wrong but it's uh the shamane the
shamane
this was written around 1000
ce okay
now in this particular story there was a
young woman named rudabah
and the uh
this guy named zal falls in love with
her
and she's also trapped in a tower i'm
not sure what the reason is
but she has super super long hair and he
wants to come visit her so she throws
the hair down so i think that that's
maybe where that long hair climbing up
the hair came from
um and also some later aspects of the
rapunzel story also maybe came from this
because
what happens
inevitably when she throws the hair down
said hey sexy prince why don't you come
up here and like visit me
um
i mean he comes up there and visits and
they hump right so she gets pregnant
and uh
now their dads are kind of like not
super happy about it because rudab is
babylonian
and sal is persian so it's like it's
like a little bit of a west side story
ramune julia type thing
um
but
you know they hop and they she gets
pregnant stuff but it's okay because the
astrologers say oh well the kid that
they have is gonna like you know rule
the world so it's gonna be fine like so
their kid is fated to be awesome so it's
okay
um
now later versions of the story though
the earliest version of the rapunzel
story probably like in a form that we
would recognize it today is from the
early 1600s now this is from a guy named
again gian batista bassily i think i
mentioned him earlier he's an italian
folklorist
and his version
uh like i said the earliest kind of
written down version that's recognizable
is you know the long-haired uh woman
trapped in the tower the prince who
comes to rescue her now
this is pretty much the version that i
read growing up
how rapunzel ends up in the tower
is that
it happens before she's even born
her mom
who lives next door to a witch or an
ogre or a fairy sometimes um you know as
one does
the mom
sees the garden
of the witch over there and it's like
man there's some really yummy [ __ ] like
growing in that garden over there i'm
gonna go over there and just like take a
couple of just let the witch won't know
because you know what i mean
um so some of the versions the mom
steals parsley
although the version i read
she actually steals
something known as rampian which is
actually called
lamb's lettuce or
another name for it is
rapunzel
so it's kind of like a it's not lettuce
exactly but it's kind of like a like a
plant you can eat it right it's like a
gardish type situation
so in that version of the story which is
the one that i read growing up
the mom steals this rampion from the
witch's garden
she gets busted
and then the witch says well i won't
kill you if
you give me your firstborn
child
so that's how rapunzel ends up in the
tower
is that the mom has to give up the baby
to the witch
so she doesn't get her ass killed yeah
now we're going old testament which
we're talking about christianity new
testament and old testament it's funny
how how the same tropes keep appearing
and all these fighters but yeah i mean
humans brains only go in like firstborn
well you're talking about the old
testament stuff so you okay
yeah
same kind of [ __ ] same thing so
so yeah so that's how she ends up so i
mean in the real quote-unquote real
story at least the one that was based on
saint barbara her dad put her in the
tower when she was older for a couple of
different reasons whereas in the fairy
tale version it's usually a witch or an
ogre or something like that and it's
usually something that the parents did
before the kid was born and then the kid
was born later the witch comes over and
is like hey remember that promise we
made you stole some [ __ ] from my garden
so
give me the baby and then she puts the
baby like up in the tower for whatever
reason i don't really know
i don't really remember if the witch had
any reason
for putting
other than she just she wanted her
because she was like taking revenge i
don't really know but yeah there was um
in the version of rapunzel that i read
growing up
um
once she's up there
it's kind of like the prince does come
up like the prince sees her she's
singing or whatever the [ __ ] and he
climbs up her hair and goes in there and
they hump and then she gets pregnant
and i think like most versions of the
fairy tale like have
sort of a happy ending although not
necessarily because what usually happens
is that rapunzel gets kicked out of the
tower and then the prince like the witch
blinds the prince
but then
sometimes i think the version i read
like rapunzel cries into his eyes or
some [ __ ] like that and like he gets his
sight back and like they live happily
ever after i think that was the version
that i read as a kid but yeah in the
real version
if saint barbara actually did live uh
she got beheaded so there wasn't a happy
ending nobody climbed up her hair she
just got [ __ ] beheaded by her dad so
you know that's that's not fun all right
so where are we at okay so we're at two
hours
and we're gonna talk about
beauty and the beast next although do
you want to do why don't you do the uh
the break let them see this okay okay
we're going to give you guys we're going
to show you guys the show it's about 10
minutes long i got to go to the bathroom
and she's going to the restroom and
[ __ ] i got to make drinks
okay well hold on we should check and
make sure they can hear the audio first
or i can
check with this it should be okay okay
because i put it on the correct setting
i think but okay that's right so here we
go all right let me know if you can hear
it
we are at the uh
what's it called the trough the trough
and use this florida
man they got some good stuff up here
fried oysters
i'm gonna get the seafood
platter what you getting what you
getting jen i'm getting coconut shrimp
coconut shrimp this is the trough i'm
going to tell you guys what it's like i
heard good things about this place at
the biker bar they said it was good
so there's that seafood platter
it looks good smells great
what was that
coconut
yeah let's see what it's like
okay that was fantastic what'd you think
jen
that's delicious yeah man i demolished
it
that was legendary
had a big piece of fish
kind of like british
fish and chips
big old thing of fish
stack of french fries underneath it
half a dozen oysters on one side
had half a dozen fried shrimp on the
other they were big big shrimp about
that big yeah
and then a pile of fried clams coleslaw
had all you can get charter sauce and
malt vinegar
but uh i think it was like 26 bucks and
that was
i i can barely i'm full i can't eat
anymore
she had the um
coconut shrimp cooked and it was it was
great it was she was dipping in some
kind of marmalade orange marmalade yeah
it was orange
yeah
and that was also great i had one of
them we traded some
but this is uh no this is a
great little place man
nice
and then um
these guys are all pulling up
in the bikes
bikers showing up they told me to come
here anyway
all right that was uh that was it we had
a good time here
[Music]
[Applause]
show you guys the outside where this is
[Applause]
got the bikers here
that's the trough
it's actually
not much really to look at
man
that was a good place
this is uh on the way to our
house it's going right yeah it's cold it
should be you got a little counter going
right there i think so yeah
this is what it looks like outside
our house we're about i don't know
five or six miles
yeah something like that it's all just
farms
and um
but this is what florida looks like
once you get outside of orlando yeah
this is kind of
i would consider this
country
yeah this is this is country rural yeah
it's out there in rural florida and
we're gonna be passing all kinds of
farms that have
cows in them
we passed one that had a sign
made out of wood
just kind of burned in there and said
honey
eggs rabbits
and they said some other stuff the farm
you can just go up there and just buy
food
grown right there
kind of like just a chef's fantasy out
here
there there there's some cows shoving
cows jack
lots of
those and then
right here at this intersection if you
turn right it goes
and it opens up
and you
ends up at where a lowe's is and stuff
but it looks like you're out in the
middle of nowhere but you're
kind of not really
not really
now you head out i mean it's not that
far to
the city
if i were to do a u-turn here
and start driving down the road i'd be
heading towards jen's mom's house
that's about about an hour away
yeah
now that's [ __ ] out in the middle of
nowhere
yes it is that's out in the middle you
can't even get a cell phone reception a
lot of yeah i get out there and i start
i start getting nervous
[Music]
not even a horror movie yeah you're not
even sure if all the houses have power
they do but
a lot of none of them don't have roads
it's just a house
house is on dirt roads
and you're like how the hell does
somebody
make a living out here
and then you look in the front yard and
they got a brand new [ __ ] harley
chopper
[ __ ]
brand new
brand new camaros you know they got
[ __ ] they got money just makes you
wonder how you know what it is that they
do they just they got their priorities
straight that's what it is [ __ ] that
house just put it get a big ass camaro
they're like well it's big enough we can
live in
camaro baby
yeah
so there's some more farms these are
everywhere that's the cows
cows are horses
yeah this is where there's there's some
cows
here are some cows yeah moo cows
damn they're gonna make me [ __ ] stop
at this red light yeah they are there's
a you big peaches
no this is where that sign was actually
well this is it's a little bit no we
didn't i think it's like this this place
you can pick your own strawberries on
beaches
we haven't checked it out yet but
there's a lot of places like that around
lots and lots of pine trees
and then
what's funny is that uh
where's the cajun boiled peanut guy yeah
i don't know
downtown orlando
is maybe 40 minutes from here
and then um yeah yeah
so it looks like you're in the middle of
nowhere but you're not really
driving jenny's [ __ ]
[Music]
taurus
we paid nothing for this car
well not nothing
four thousand for this car
2 000 no 1800 1800
this for nearly 10 years now
so we got our money's worth out of this
don't jinx it yeah that's what we got
out there
they're growing some
trees food
weed yeah maybe
get these is that a dooley i don't know
no it's not dude yeah it's a dooley
so you know redneck when he's got four
wheels on the back four wheels on the
back and two up front got the dualies
that way he can haul those horse
trailers
my stepdad had a dooley
he was proud of that [ __ ] too
piece of [ __ ] you could buy them for
nothing here
it's really weird watching the road go
by like on the tablet
well because i'm getting kind of dizzy
because i don't have my glasses on so
it's like
all i can see is like the blurry road
ahead that's right i have to keep like
it's okay kind of dizzy like yeah so
we're letting everybody on the show
ride in a car with us
in the car in the car with us show them
some southern houses see they got
everything
they got everything out there
see
to let you guys know yeah they got booty
out there too all kinds of booty
like pirate booty all kinds of booty
that's over here
okay show them that yeah it's hard for
me to see they got all the horses
horses and horse trailers
farm houses
[Music]
yeah and just
farm houses
farms
that's the one where you can buy the
rabbits sunshine acres sunshine acres
you just pull in with your car and you
gotta got your rabbits how many you want
what are they a pound i don't ask all
that how many of them
probably
don't ask all that i ain't got any time
for that how many raps
that's what they're gonna say they weigh
as much as a rabbit yeah yeah weigh as
much as a rabbit if there's nothing
enough i wouldn't have killed him
it weighs all your weight is safe
they all weigh the same
how much is it a pound we ain't gonna
worry about that
how much of rabbit five dollars rabbit
there's gonna be some [ __ ] like that
i don't know i have to check it might be
five probably five dollars a rabbit
probably
somewhere between five and ten
they don't cost much
or at least they used to not cost much i
don't want to eat a little cute money
i don't want to eat a little coupon oh
i'll eat them if they're already getting
killed i just don't want to be like
angel and pull their heads off
yeah
i'm not really into that no
i can cut their head off but she just
puts him in
pops that pops the skulls off of them
pops
it doesn't break off but it breaks their
necks
there's all the there's all the cows
they're chilling
cow community meeting
out there talking with the birds
yeah what do you think about the current
cow situation yeah you're talking about
mabel
you got out here
yeah this really is kind of out in the
middle of nowhere now that i'm looking
at it yeah yeah
maybe if you've got [ __ ] like this and
pops up you go what's that we don't know
i don't know what that is we don't know
it has something to do with shipping
something to fair it's not even marked
just
no i think it's like a nursery nursery
probably it's either a nursery or a
chicken stock
yeah it's even
nursery you get all the babies you want
we got all kinds of babies it took them
forever to finish that house i've been
passing that house for over [ __ ] 20
years looking yeah it was
built piece by piece
like it almost didn't look like a house
yeah it's like a like a bank it was all
cinderblock guy made it out a whole
thing out of cinder blocks well ours is
too oh yeah but the whole thing is
cinder blocks that's a weird like cold
church i think of rafiki yeah more
nurseries by trees
yeah there's all kinds of nurseries
right here
there's one like right by our house that
you can go and
work at
like you can do peace work and they'll
pay you like per day yeah per day you're
out there with all the [ __ ] children
pulling back pulling those little
trailers around
looking picking picking up little pots
of plants and [ __ ] they got a lot of i
don't call them [ __ ] children they
got [ __ ] yeah that's uh
they got
mentally handicapped children working in
there
[Music]
they pay you by buy the plant
yeah so you have to work your ass off
probably make any damn money there well
yeah you probably do but like i said
it's just kind of like if people want
like meat
extra money and there's like i was
dropped in there and worked a couple
days and
yeah make
okay we're home
oh [ __ ] that's home now
yeah this is uh this is our neighborhood
here this is this is black bear
black bear reserves
[Music]
there's little i don't know if you can
see them on the thing because i can't
see but there's little bitty black bear
statues
trying not to i'm trying to hold it up
so i don't get like the dashboard you
know what i mean
but then i'm like it's blurry and then
all i can see is my reflection this is
our house here
yeah
get into the driveway
there we go there it is
all right signing off
all right yep done with that so
hopefully everybody enjoyed that
well i got to run to the bathroom you
didn't even make any new drinks during
that time i could make some more during
that bowl
i was just monitoring everything making
sure he was going smoothly he wants to
listen to himself talk is what it is i
was listening to the comments
[Laughter]
she says that's a pretty home yeah oh no
we got a we got a nice house
and and actually we don't have one of
the nicest houses here they got a lot
nicer [ __ ] up here once i get my gopro
i'll put it on my helmet and i'll take
them take you all out for a motorcycle
ride and i'll show you all the houses in
here and the private lake and they got
private the houses are on the lake they
got little [ __ ] private landings and
they go out there with the boat and you
can go out there with the paddle boat
and fish on it
and then [ __ ] go out that way and you
have all kinds of circle k's and
and
general stores and biker bars and uh
supermarkets and everything i'll take
you guys on too well i mean i kind of
want to do more vlogging type of stuff
like whenever we go somewhere but it's
like i always kind of forget you know
what i mean right it's easier to like
film stuff when you take your tablet
someplace yeah because my phone is not
it doesn't have enough memory to like do
like long videos yeah it's got it's got
palm trees it's a cross between like
forest
um
cattle ranches and south and central
america it's got palm trees and all
kinds of stuff and um
pretty lakes and we're not far from the
ocean
either
well i mean
kind of kind of no that's a [ __ ] 30
miles it's not far 40 miles an hour yeah
something like that i mean like i said i
grew up like right by the ocean so it
seems far now
but because i used to live right by it i
could see it from my window back in the
old days
but not so much anymore
um all right so hugo says that was a
nice clip guys thanks for sharing thank
you i was gonna wait till the end but
whatever but i was kind of figured
i might put it up like on its own i kind
of felt like i don't know maybe
that in the pookie in beijing
uh
playlist where i'm putting the cat
videos
it's like whenever we
record a vlog which we don't usually
like i said because
my phone is
it doesn't really have like the memory
capability to do like good videos
he his does like his tablet does but he
doesn't really take it like a lot of
times when we go someplace it's kind of
pain in the ass like it's big like to
carry around but
if we remember like we'll
you know record stuff that 10 minute
ride back was pretty much how long it
takes to get from that restaurant
well yeah we started filming like almost
all yeah that's about how far the
restaurant was
there's not a lot
that's within
like i said the only thing that's within
walking distance of our house is the
dollar general
and even that it's a little bit far but
you could still walk there if you had to
but
there's a publix there's a chinese
restaurant there's a
breakfast and lunch place brunch place
and there's the japanese restaurant
but
other than that there's really not a lot
of restaurants within i mean there's a
subway inside the gas station
like there's a circle k that has a
subway in it but i've never eaten at
that subway i'm not a big fan of subway
but yeah
all right so while he's gone let me
start on the actual topic
so
here's our third story we're gonna talk
about beauty and the beast
now this one
i kind of found this like
i don't know i kind of found this one
like really interesting because this one
seems like it has the closest
where the real thing is like the closest
equivalent
to the actual thing that happened in the
story
so
this uh the story of beauty and the
beast has actually been around for
thousands of years i mean it's a very
very old piece of folklore
um but in 1740 uh there was a kind of
famous version of it uh published in
france called
in
la
but you know obviously beating the beast
um
and
this original story
it's kind of similar to the one that
most people are familiar with nowadays
like from the disney story but
back in 1740
the sort of uh
moral of beauty and the beast was hey
ladies
let's just uh whoever it is that you're
forced to marry or betrothed to or
whatever you just gotta like [ __ ]
suck it up and live with it roll with it
even if he's a beast or if he acts like
that or whatever so that was kind of
like the moral of the story back then
yeah but you just have to deal with
let's clarify this a little bit
that was the moral of the story for rich
white girls
other women married whoever the [ __ ]
they wanted well yeah yeah rich white
girls were forced to marry
they were worth money
yeah yeah
i mean and we've gone into that a lot of
times like like i said i don't know
it seemed like you were kind of if
you're a woman back then you were damned
if you did in damage you didn't like you
really
you kind of were in a shitty situation
whether you had money or not
you know what i mean if you had money
yeah then
you know that's obviously better because
you weren't like suffering like other
people but you would also be like forced
into like marriages you didn't want you
had to put up with some [ __ ] you
probably hated you had to do all this
other [ __ ] you didn't want to do your
your life wasn't your own
um but at least your life was maybe
marginally more comfortable than most
people's
then again if you're poor
or you know working class-ish that
probably sucked a lot too because your
living conditions were probably
not ideal um but at least you had the
freedom to
maybe work if you wanted to marry who
you wanted to [ __ ] like that so i don't
know i don't know what i would pick to
be honest with you it seems like it just
suckage all around um
suckage all around from a woman's point
of view the best
most normal thing to be in terms of a
[ __ ] normal life would have been
a mixed race octoroon or quadrant woman
in new orleans
it probably would have been the best
because you would have been in a
contract with a rich dude who would take
care of you and your children
um you had mostly a normal life they
were kind of the geisha of the [ __ ]
of the song which like i said came with
its own set of like [ __ ] you didn't want
to do because you probably had to like
well they lived in mud they lived in
luxury yeah they but they were able to
choose the man who they went into into a
contract with
say yeah that was the difference i mean
other women couldn't choose right
i mean i was reading a book about
uh you know women that were like madams
and stuff like that like back in the
victorian era and before
and it's like jesus christ that's the
second time you've done that i'm drunk
yeah obviously um but
in a way like that sounds better because
in some ways you had money and it was
yours and you could do what you wanted
people didn't really [ __ ] um and people
didn't [ __ ] with you you didn't really
like have to adhere to the same
standards but
you still maybe had to [ __ ] some people
you maybe weren't all that happy about
[ __ ] but
to be honest that's probably the
direction i would go yeah because that's
like a little bit i think so it's like
you know yeah that sucks but
most of the other [ __ ] would probably go
back and look at the new orleans group
research the history of the new orleans
octoroon ball scene
okay and you would see that
that was dating
it was friends with benefits and dating
but at least to the people that were
involved in that relationship both sides
had agreed to that relationship
and according to most people that
recorded it
the white dudes that entered those
relationships actually did love those
women they didn't love their wives they
didn't choose well that was all set up
it was all set up by their family it was
a financial trend it was financial trust
i mean people who think of like marriage
as like a thing like you know you marry
somebody you love that's a fairly recent
invention that's fairly recent before
that it was just like a financial or a
political consideration a rich white
dude was forced into a marriage with
some chick and it was because of
merging family it's like we need that
land or we need like a treaty with those
people over there so yeah and she may
have been may have been but ugly or just
[ __ ] boring and you mostly boring or
she didn't like him and she had some
other she was humping the stable boy
right
but he was able to choose his mistress
but the mistress at least in the south
if you were rich
was an octoroon all right now there were
white girls that were
pretending to be octoroons because that
was a kind of a prestigious
position
uh the octoroons were the
geisha of the south
they
they're in the contract it was you will
send the children to this school or that
school the you will have this apartment
this is how much i get a month as a
[ __ ] living allowance
and we will have a relationship that was
the relationship he chose he paid for it
but he was also choosing that girl and
she allowed it
that was the closest thing you would
have to a normal relationship if today
is considered to be the norm
because she at least had some semblance
of some say in it right sure
which you know right you didn't have
complete say in it but you had more say
than there was uh the octoroon ball
scene of course is uh
uh you know kind of a big new orleans
thing guys from all over the south went
there to go find octoroon mistresses
and it's kind of considered to be like a
prom
um this is the uh the closest thing to
romance
uh upper-class white dude knew
was to go to the october ball
okay it was a very different world
normal relationship it was it's the
victorian and pre-victorian era normal
relationships between men and women
didn't exist everything was
everything was ritualized stylized like
something out of japan
oh you can really the south really was
very much like
medieval japan
or tokogawa era japan
it was daimyos and fiefdoms and
it was um [ __ ]
what do you call them class hierarchy
everything was like that so what do they
call
um class hierarchy what's another word
like in india uh [ __ ] what do they
call that a caste system
like a caste system and everything was
real
formalized
nothing was really natural
you know
that's just the way it was
mary connolly says men worked set up to
sundown women's work was never done
tammy says amen yeah
well
yeah what your class was well the thing
about it is that women are kind of have
always throughout history been expected
to be caregivers
so
you know the rich ones obviously got
away with other [ __ ] but everyone else
right um
you were kind of expected to like take
care of everybody
poor white women basically did laundry
or picked and picked butter beans
especially in the south that's what you
do you pick butter beans you paint plant
crops you share cropping uh you did
laundry yeah you took care of the
children which is a full-time job all
the time right there it worked a lot
cooking and you never and you didn't get
a break i mean it's not like you got a
break no but that was all they knew
i mean that doesn't make it better i'm
just saying but the men weren't that
much better off
maybe they were getting drunk
that was well yeah they probably were
yeah but like i said they had that
luxury they're like hey the women will
take care of all this well i think the
women got drunk too far
i would as well yeah
if i i would as well because you know
i'm i'm old enough to where i remember
the tail end of it in mississippi
see
now this was my dad's
parents
generation now his parents
were middle class but his friend's
parents were sharecropper class and i
remember them they were still alive i
remember how they lived
they were wild though they were very
wild
especially when they were younger
but it was just
very very third world this is not the
america you know more like central and
south america
mary points out too that it's like it's
not like nowadays where you have like
all the modern conveniences
women had to do everything from scratch
you had to cook everything from scratch
yeah uh you had to do canning she says
make soap sewing you had to sew people's
clothes yeah
vegetable garden yeah grow things in the
garden skinning food you know beating
the carpets out yeah there weren't any
like convenience yeah conveniences you
had to do everything
yourself right but it wasn't just the
women the men the men too were doing it
they were working in together
it wasn't just women women and the men
also took care of kids but they just did
it in a different way they were one of
the disciplinarians of kids
but no they they were planting and doing
all that same thing from and i'm not
pulling this out of my ass that's what i
saw
that's what i saw in the [ __ ]
late 70s and early 80s and mississippi
said you felt better i was still doing
it
so it wasn't
sexist per se it was just families
trying to survive
you know the men and the women were
trying to survive and that was the
sharecropper class which that's where on
my dad's side that's where where i'm
coming from uh even though
his parents were i would say town middle
class at that time
but they didn't come from that
you know what i mean that that took a
couple generations to get from there and
they were still friends with everybody
else
they were still kind of or related in
certain ways to people that were kind of
sharecropper class
elvis was a sharecropper his family
it was not as far back as you think it
is it's it's weird
when you kind of analyze it
time goes by quickly
[Laughter]
a few generations back america was a
third third world country compared to
what it is now
tila says i would stay drunk back then
and i would be very much be into buddha
yeah i don't blame you
i probably would have done the same if
you were in the south i can't imagine
there's no way i'd i'd probably be like
[ __ ] man if i was alive back in the
colonial days that have been burned as a
witch like first day
a lot of that [ __ ] was going on during
the victorian era so there was a lot of
self-imposed inhibition
depending on your social class didn't
matter well it's not so much
self-imposed it's culture imposed i mean
nobody is imposing those standards on
themselves i guess you could say but
it's just
it that's like the larger you can't like
operate in that culture if you're not
if you're not conforming to a certain
sense there's more than one culture's
happening simultaneously well i know
that but i'm just saying that in the
larger
context you can't just like go back to
the victory like if i went back in a
time machine and acted like me in the
victorian era
that would you didn't have a jail that
would not fly you'd end up in jail that
would not fly right
no way
if i went back to the 1600s they would
burn me alive
maybe
probably the first day i should show you
where you went probably and how what
your language skills were like
if you were to hang out with a criminal
class they'd probably think you were
awesome
or maybe even the royal class it's
always the extremes that's what i mean
you can't go into like the mainstream
show you always gotta go like really
really rich or really really really poor
you're right yeah
so at all it's the people who were free
you know
most people were never free not really
there was a lot of social restrictions
on them
but
it also depended on what city you were
in new orleans was very yeah it's it's
never sure across the board it's like
never [ __ ] yeah generic depends on
where you went
okay
i mean new orleans was a pirate hangout
going back to the 1500s so you could get
away with a lot of [ __ ] i mean me
personally right
um
[Music]
if somebody invented a time machine and
said to me jenny you can go back to any
like time period that you wanted to go
to
i don't think i would right
i mean being a woman
being kind of like a weirdo i'm just
kind of like
i just can't see this going well
when i like whatever time period i go to
i just i wouldn't risk it i'd no thanks
no thanks when you go back to the
[ __ ] 40
to the 16 1700s
you know 16 and 1700s in the new world
the cool place to be was the pirate
scene it didn't matter what your gender
was or your sex or your gender or your
race
if you were a good pirate you you could
[ __ ] have a lot of fun i mean if
somebody pirates were not illegal they
had charters to be pirates that's what i
mean
now if if somebody if i got like thrown
back to like like an evil dead yeah
three you want to be a pirate like if i
got thrown back to like some time period
that i was uh then yeah that i would
probably be like trying to find the
pirates and get involved with that
because i i'm not fitting in with it no
they were the punk rockers of the time
yeah and the [ __ ] out they were doing
the fire they were
they were the the
non-conformists but you also have to
understand that they raped robbed and
[ __ ] murdered people too i'm not
saying it's an ideal situation i'm just
saying that if somebody forced me to go
back in time to that time period and i
didn't have any other options
yeah i'm not getting my ass tortured and
killed come on they called that [ __ ]
democracy back then they were like well
[ __ ] we're all gonna divide this [ __ ]
we all have equal say and what the
mission is gonna be and blah blah blah
blah they didn't care
and you had black people you had indians
you had [ __ ] chinese style people
and or part chinese people and white
people of all different european
versions of of us
and they all had them out there on the
seas with a legal charter to go steal
[ __ ] from some enemy of some king
and uh they were able to do whatever the
[ __ ] they wanted but if you got caught
by the another superpower they'd hang
you for it
they were mercenaries
but they were also free in a certain
expense and it's they were outside of
society
uh most people said yeah the [ __ ]
pirates are cool but they were also the
enemies of mankind
that's how they were that's how they
were described they were even blackbeard
[ __ ] once his wife pissed him off he
[ __ ] gave her over to the crew to do
whatever they wanted to her they ran a
train on her
and then he [ __ ] got rid of her
because she was making fun of him over
his socks
you know she had been [ __ ] with him
her she was from a rich family she was a
little excessive she evidently was
[ __ ] berating him and kept
disrespecting him in front of the crew
and then finally
talking about his [ __ ] socks his
dirty socks and he's like we're gonna
run a train on you [ __ ] [ __ ] he
shared her with the [ __ ] crew and
then threw her threw her overboard at
some port [ __ ] her
so you have to be careful with these
[ __ ] they were criminals they were
mercenaries yeah that seems
out of proportion yeah
look i make fun of yourself dad her dad
was her dad i would hope that you would
not like pull down holy crap
she was the one that went out of her way
to marry him and then she wanted to use
him as some kind of a [ __ ]
um
uh uh
[ __ ] way of [ __ ] uh
she wanted to use she was trying to use
him as a what do you call it
oh man what's the word
i don't know i don't know to make
herself seem more important um i
remember anyway her dad was like the
governor of coo
of cuba i think i think it was cooper or
governor of puerto rico her dad was real
important
we ought to do a [ __ ] story we had to
do a show on the pirates because there's
those motherf that's a true crime story
right well and to be honest oh [ __ ] that
they did
we could do a whole show about
pirate [ __ ] that just happened in
florida yeah okay we can do that because
yeah
look if you go to st augustine if you go
to tampa clearwater so there's all kind
of like pirate there's pirate wrecks
yeah
out like off the coast yeah saint
augustine has a pirate museum there's
all kind of [ __ ] they found out
all kind of like fun stuff yeah so i
don't have anything against them that's
actually a good idea i don't look for
any of you pirates out there i have a
book
i bought like last time remember when i
went on vacation to saint augustine yeah
and when i was at the pirate museum
which is awesome by the way you should
go go like during
when kids are not off school
because kids love that place
and when i was there it was summer so
the place was like crawling with
children yeah
um but go in the winter
but it's cool otherwise
now they have like all of these like
[ __ ] that they've
found like from pirate rex
off of florida and it's amazing like all
the [ __ ] they found like all the
treasure and whatnot
i bought a book while i was in there
which i've been wanting to read anyway
that book called under the black flag
and it's all about like kind of the
history of pirates in general
i haven't read it yet
um i've got around to it but
i bought it there
and
i kind of feel like
i don't know florida is big on the part
like tampa the whole like gulf of mexico
tampa gulf of mexico area
they have a whole uh kind of pirate
history that a lot of people don't know
about and st augustine on the east coast
yeah also has a lot of pirate history so
florida has like a lot of pirate [ __ ]
t understands how to talk about she says
what i'm talking about it's called
plessage yeah plessage
that was that was with the uh the octone
of balls i believe that completely that
was
placeage
yeah placing some woman with
that that little thing that's under the
city of this we have it in portuguese
yeah it's the same thing in french same
thing in french that's a soft replacing
a woman of high value with a man of high
value
uh because we can't let her go to waste
you know i'm talking about that's what
they're talking about plus size
and because you can't let this woman
just marry this rabble you know that's
what they're talking about
tammy says please do a pirate show we
can do what we should do we totally
should because there's all kinds of [ __ ]
that they did that would make total
sense they were professionals
psychological warfare ever thief edward
thatch or edward teach whatever his name
was there's a lot of real good
pirates
uh we we need to do a show about we'll
do some florida oriented pirate stuff
that's what i'm saying because it's like
it's a big topic but
like i said yeah if you go to st
augustine or if you hang out in you know
tampa or the west coast of florida
there's a lot of like pirate mythology
because a lot of pirate [ __ ] went down
yeah and there's a good one about
florida park it's called the island
yeah one of my favorite movies watch the
grill watching it
with old wess's name
david warner no and michael caine
michael caine and david david warner why
did i think well david warner and
they've drive right down through orlando
[ __ ] on the movie right down pirate
somewhere where's my where's my pad
where'd he go oh i took him in the
bedroom okay let me go get another drink
because i was writing down like other
topics yeah
yeah we should do a pirate show okay i'm
gonna i'll put it in the next poll i
promise
like if somebody if he writes it down or
if he brings me some [ __ ] and i'll write
it down
and i'll put it in the next poll because
the next poll doesn't go until friday
so what are we talking about beauty and
the beast
okay so there was actually
a real story behind
beauty and the beast
and as i said
i kind of found this fascinating because
this was actually like pretty
close to the actual story which is crazy
so this is a real life story um going
back to the 1530s
now
the dude the beast if you know it that
we're talking about
uh was a kid
named petrus
gonzalvus
now
he kind of came to prominence in about
1537
and
when he was 10 years old
he got sent to the court of king henry
ii
as a
curiosity
because
this
unfortunate child
had
um
a
malady
that made him look like
a werewolf
so
like i said this is the thing well like
back then they didn't know what it was
nowadays we know what it is it's called
a hypertrichosis
and it's basically a
disease
that makes you grow hair all over your
body so it's like a genetic
it's essentially like a genetic
throwback you're
a human but you look like you have hair
all over your body like a like another
mammal
um
again this might be where the werewolf
myth came from
so this kid
who was born in spain
and
he was born and he had hair all over his
body
and because it was the 1500s
everybody was like ooh look at this
weird baby
let's profit off of it because that's
how they did
so
they sent him to like
various royal courts because that was
like a big thing back in the day like
you'd have
the royal court and they'd be all kind
of like
we're very rich and we're very bored
so bring us some
freakish humans to entertain us
because we have nothing better to do
apparently
so they're kidnapping kids that look
like werewolves
and they're
shipping them to
take them for their families they didn't
give [ __ ]
so they're kind of like uh you know
shipping them to like whatever and
they're they're doing that
now uh obviously he's a big hit
everybody comes to see him
like look at that little kid that looks
like a [ __ ] werewolf that's crazy
um
and they would come to see him and
they were kind of okay so they were kind
of bummed out though because they kind
of expected him because he was covered
in hair
and looked like a werewolf he's only a
little kid
remember
they kind of expected him to act like an
animal too except he didn't because he
was a person
and he was actually a pretty chill
person so he's just kind of like i don't
know what you guys are like expecting me
to do i'm not
like they wanted him to like act like an
animal and he just wasn't having it
because like
hey
hi i'm i'm a person i'm just covered
with hair i don't know what your deal is
so there's that
so like i said this is an actual disease
we know what it is now but they didn't
know what it is back then
now
uh the king at the time
he kind of like uh took shine to the kid
he's like okay um
i'm gonna like
adopt this kid essentially kind of and
he's gonna do like a weird he's like i'm
gonna dress them up in little noblemen
clothes
and i'm going to
teach him like nobleman kind of manners
i don't know if he thought that would be
funny or i don't know i don't know but
i don't know he he seemed to like the
kid
so but so he bought him all these little
clothes
and he taught him all these little
manners
and he gave him an education
so there was that
and
so at this point like the kid is getting
older obviously he's still covered in
hair but
in every other respect he's like a
normal
quote-unquote nobleman
so at this point we're like we have to
find him a wife
because that would just like cement the
whole
normalcy situation
so
catherine de medici
who was married to king henry ii at the
time
she said
i'm going to find this little
weirdo i'm sure that's how she thought
of him a wife
so
you know king henry ii dies and
catherine de medici takes the throne
over
and she's like well i'm gonna find him a
wife that's gonna be one of my main
things that i'm gonna do
she also hoped this is pretty [ __ ] up
she's like well
if i find this
werewolf boy essentially a wife
maybe
they will have children and there will
be more werewolf children
and
we can
sell them or display them in other
because like i said you have to think
this was
a while but like nobody thought of
people that were born with deformities
or you know genetic
[ __ ] up-ness as a person they didn't
think of them as a person they just
thought of them as like an entertainment
so
if more of them were born
they were like chi-ching
that's kind of how they thought of them
yeah cash crop yeah because it's like
everybody will want to come see this
like weirdo
that's which is [ __ ] up but that's how
they thought of it
so
she says okay we're gonna find this
little werewolf boy
a wife
and then maybe they'll reproduce and
then they'll have more of them and then
i'll have more like [ __ ] to sell over
that's like that's messed up
now when she was looking around for a
wife though they were doing like some
weird
i feel like it was maybe like the
bachelorette
type situation the reality show
um but she didn't tell anybody
that the bachelor that they were
applying to mary
was
uh covered with hair
lit you know what i mean
like she left that detail out of the
tinder profile is what i'm saying
um so she was looking for
someone who
she was looking for a woman that kind of
had some like [ __ ] substance that
wouldn't be
she's not going to tell her ahead of
time but she wanted a woman that wasn't
going to be like alarmed
when she saw her
grim to be
that was entirely covered with hair
she's like i want somebody that's just
gonna like take that with some grace
so that takes a special kind of woman i
guess
so she waited a long time until she
found the person
so she finally finds a woman
that she thinks fits the bill
this woman is also named katherine i
don't know what her last name is it's
wasn't recorded
now
they decided so i guess they arranged
the marriage
before
catherine
had seen
the dude that she was going to marry
all that she knew was that it was a
nobleman
that he had some money that he had the
favor
of
you know the king and catherine de
medici and stuff like that so it seemed
like a good match
so she comes in
uh story goes
then she as she was a young beautiful
woman she comes in
to
marry this mystery man
and
uh
she was a little um
surprised let's put it that way
nobleman comes out he has all the
clothes on he's very articulate and
stuff like that but
he looks like a werewolf
which
you know
not judging but that would be a little
alarming
so
what ended up happening though was that
so they marry them off because that was
the deal
but what ended up happening just like in
the beauty and the b story was that
catherine evidently even though she was
initially weirded out
by what he looked like
was kind of like you know what um he's
kind of awesome like he was an awesome
dude like his personality was awesome
and she was uh kind of won over by that
so much so
that uh after they got married
they actually ended up married for 40
years
and had seven
kids
so
apparently she was uh down
you know and it was okay
now uh happily for catherine de medici
who kind of arranged this whole thing
three of the children
that they
had
had the same thing
hypertrochosis where they had hair all
over their bodies
uh
so
at this point in time they had the whole
traveling sideshow thing like i said
they didn't really consider people that
had deformities or any kind of like
genetic anomalies or anything like that
they didn't really consider them
i don't want to say they didn't consider
them human but they really were kind of
like hey you're just like for our you're
here for our amusement so we'll just do
whatever we want to you
uh so basically they took those three
kids away from them they're like hey we
need them for like some circuses and
[ __ ] so
come on so they took those kids away
and uh actually ended up gifting them to
other royal families who thought it
would be amusing to have a werewolf
child around so
you know it wasn't much amusement back
then i guess can you imagine how [ __ ]
up let's like let's have like some
deformed child can we buy that from
somewhere yeah we'll put it that will
entertain me for some the guests will
see it they'll love it i can't imagine
being that [ __ ] bored yeah
that you need like some
person that has some unfortunate yeah
that's like a draw at your parties
it was i see it that's [ __ ] up yeah
like i said that's nice stop it poop
i don't know she's just gonna do it
she's she blows me off she's like [ __ ]
you dad
well you're not tearing up i mean you
don't do anything well you shouldn't do
anything i don't do this she's like i'm
gonna do it anyway we kind of yell at
her and she's just kind of like what and
whatever yeah y'all yell y'all talking
funny but like i said we're not gonna do
anything i'm not gonna smack her or
anything like that why would i do that
that would be me
but yeah so
there are three so they had three kids
that had the same uh genetic disorder
and they were taken away
um
now
some of the other
uh children in the family that looked
quote unquote normal
were actually taken away and educated
and they actually ended up being like
members of court and stuff but
one of the girls i think who also had
the same
genetic disorder and was covered with
hair
um was actually painted in some
portraits and stuff like that so she was
like kind of famous
but
so
yeah so this was like actually a real
story they didn't record what happened
like the
the normal looking quote-unquote woman
and the werewolf looking dude
actually ended up moving to
some like
kind of remote place in italy
after which history kind of lost track
of them but that's
where they think a lot of the aspects of
the beauty and the bee story came from
because it did actually happen she did
marry like a werewolf dude
whose personality was like super nice
but yeah so that's where that came from
all right so
what are they what are they talking
about is the book better it's about it
from the island oh right right yeah i
don't know i haven't read it but wait
was it did um did peter benchley write
that the same guy that wrote jaws
i think maybe i think i think so i feel
like i remembered that that was a peter
benjalino but i haven't read it i read
jaws i read some of his other [ __ ] one
of our big subscribers i forgot which
one it was
said that they read the book and the
book is even better
but it usually is the movie of the
island is very good michael kane
1981 maybe around that time
um
but evidently the book is a lot more
detailed and i don't want to spoil it
it's just a book it's just a movie you
got to see
because there's reveals in it
and
it's about pirates
pirates in the modern age
hit me with my pens and like is there a
piece of paper over there
i need to write it down or i'll forget
there's pens i don't see anything
there's pens
there should be pens right there
where
jesus
i don't see anything there's no pens no
there's pens get out and go look okay
i don't see well you talk then look at
you look at her get up go look for fans
i didn't well how could that how could i
see that that's what i see that
i can't see that [ __ ]
okay go i couldn't see this
there's three bands i couldn't see it i
thought you know there were three pens
okay right there see how she does oh
three times right now all right
i'm just saying
three pants
go ahead what are you writing down and
there's paper pirates okay
because i want to remember because i
will put it in the poll all right before
friday okay
so we'll put florida pirates because if
i don't write it down then i will
correct
all right so we got one more story and
we're going to talk about
bluebeard
and i kind of feel like somebody like
mentioned that we should talk about
bluebeard so we're talking about
bluebeard right now all right
all right
so the story of bluebeard
i feel like most people are kind of
familiar with the story but let's go
over it
so bluebeard
the fairy tale
deals with uh
some
kind of like un yeah i don't know
unexplained like aristocrat or whatever
we don't think about the books is yes
the guy that did josh
i thought it was yeah it's peter
benchley right
i don't think i
she bought the book i didn't read that
book i read jaws
i will say that jaws is one of the very
few
instances where the movie was better
than the book the book is good
but the book had a lot of like uh
extraneous
[ __ ] in it yeah
that was wisely cut out of the movie it
really did not need to be in there well
you get away within the book but in the
movie yeah no once you read the book
go and see the movie too
all right they say that they say the
book is better but the movie is also
really good
all right
i
is it as good as jaws
no
no they're different they're different
i liked it i liked them both i like them
both did peter benchley also write
the deep
maybe
i don't know i feel like i read that
book i don't know the movie had
jacqueline bessette in it
i remember it being
okay but i was expecting
i don't know like i remember like
reading the book and seeing the movie i
was like i expected more sharks or more
killer squids or something
and i feel like it was it was kind of
like a treasure hunt type story
you know okay i kind of felt like it was
it was good but it wasn't like his
i don't know i thought yeah i thought
more people would be in my shirt as good
as josh i mean the jaws jaws is a very
concise and of course the direction the
director and everything and just jaws is
[ __ ] epic it's epic
uh but the island is good too um
when you when you watch it you'll see
what i'm talking about i don't want any
spoilers it's just a
it's a good adventure
good adventure movie that has a good
cast
that has a [ __ ] weird premise and a
lot of really interesting characters in
it
i i i in a good and a good moral lesson
it was like modern man versus old school
man what was the difference and and they
show it in the movie there was a
difference
they both had their strengths but they
and they both had their weaknesses
it's not it's not a judgmental movie
uh but you just can't beat modern man
and a 50 caliber bmg belfast machine gun
in the end that's what it that's what
that [ __ ] shows the the modernity gonna
win
spoiler alert yeah modernity has certain
advantages we have nuclear bombs right
right right and gps that and that's kind
of what the [ __ ] movie says yeah the
old school dudes
had certain strengths but they were dumb
and [ __ ] they didn't know everything
and uh
they misunderstood things that they saw
but yeah they were brave of course they
were and that's what the movie's about
yeah tila said not much is as good as
jaws i mean jaws
that's kind of like the gold
standard of monster movies the gold
standard of nature run among movies
i mean
the gold center of like yeah blockbuster
movies right everything the moral lesson
behind the book is that
and it's about manhood really and
fatherhood you know when you see the
movie is that the modern man is really
should combine the two modernity and
ancient tradition really should be
combined
into the same man you have to understand
everything
you should know the way it was and the
way it is now
and
that's really what that book is about
and that's what that movie is about yeah
i liked him it's just kind of like a uh
you know it's basically just saying be
well-rounded be well-rounded yeah that's
what it's saying which i think is like a
good
right that that's good advice be ready
for whatever the time period
be flexible be well flexible be ready
for anything know a little bit about
everything right that's what it's
talking about you know that's all don't
be too caught up in like oh
[ __ ] or the old area or nation you
should be able to do everything sure
right that's what it's doing be kind of
like outside of that right but take bits
from every thing thank you yeah thank
you that's all it is yeah
that's not crazy no that's not great no
it's great that's a great it's great
advice that's what i mean because every
well
well there's kind of a thing where it's
like old old school blah blah or the new
thing oh nothing's good nowadays
that's always [ __ ] no it's always
there's always good [ __ ] to take just
take good [ __ ] from every time period
and put it all together and put it all
together right that gives you like
stress strength weakness is weakness
that gives you that well you have to
have like a good like wide range wide
range and it all should go together
right
that's all and that's what that's what
the book is about that's what the movie
is about
and i enjoyed the movie i haven't read
the book
uh there are some some subscribers when
i mentioned it they said how much better
the book was
um
now i kind of want to read it yeah maybe
i wonder is that freon kindle and
liberty
if it is i'll read it because i have
kennel
all right so where was i i was talking
about
blueberry
all right bluebeard boy that's a [ __ ]
hardcore story right there
yeah it's kind of messed up yeah as a
serial killer story
yeah yeah we'll get into that
so uh t said yes he did write the deep
yeah i thought so yeah okay
like i said i remember
seeing that movie because i knew
that
peter brenchley was like oh this would
do the road jobs maybe they'll be sharks
there are sharks in the deep but it's
not
the main point of the story because it's
mostly like a treasure hunt story as far
as i remember
it's good but i don't know i i should
probably like re-watch it because i kind
of feel like i watched it back then
thinking it was going to be jaws i'm
like when is somebody getting eaten by a
show why is nobody getting by shark this
is
you know what i mean yeah so you know i
don't know i can watch it again it's
probably good jacqueline was in it
so
yeah blue beard now first recorded the
the first recorded instance of the story
uh was from france in the 1600s
now
many people have there's a couple of
different stories that people think uh
maybe inspired the bluebeard story like
a couple of uh actual historical figures
one of which we've already covered but
i'll get into it a little bit
um
although i must say that versions of
this story
do exist
in older folklore not exactly the way
the bluebeard story is but there's
aspects of it so
it might be a case of
older kind of like folkloric stories
like clashing with
you know actual
people or actual legends that spring up
about actual people
so uh
the brothers grimm did a version of it
uh although probably in this case the
most famous version is by uh charles
perrault
who also did probably the definitive
version of the cinderella story as well
he's a french folklorist
so there's that
now
the first printed version of bluebeard
uh
was from a short story published by uh
the aforementioned charles bro in 1697.
he had a compilation called tales of
pastimes i'm not even gonna attempt to
pronounce the french
name
uh but that's what the english version
is
now according to his story this like i
said this first print version that it
had been around like prior to this
bluebeard is a really rich guy and he
has a beard that's blue and it's really
ugly
and so all of the women that would
potentially marry him are really put off
by it because it's a little weird having
a beard that's blue i guess
so
in order to kind of show everybody he's
a cool guy
he has like this big party
at his big country house
he has a whole week of
you know [ __ ] planned and he invites all
these single ladies like i said it's
almost kind of like
one of those reality shows it's like a
reality show back in the old days yeah
he invites all these ladies look i'm not
look i have a blue beard but
i'm i'm really a good guy yeah i swear
yeah we're like it's almost kind of like
it's like the bachelorette we know a lot
of blue-haired girls but i don't know
about any blue beard dudes i've never
met a dupe with a blueberry you got the
blue hair on right i have blue hair red
and i don't even oh you got the blue
hair on right now yeah
that was completely accidental i just
wore this because i didn't feel like
like washing my hair today
that was like
it's black at the top and blue at the
bottom yeah yeah yeah it's actually a
natural i have a great i have a gradient
yeah but yeah i didn't like i didn't
even like think of that but i was like
oh now i can look like i meant to do
that but yeah so he invites all these
ladies over
as though it was his own bachelorette
reality show program
i kind of feel like that's what i that's
what i felt
um
now
one of these ladies that shows up at
this party
she's like oh look at this look at this
intriguing fellow
and she's kind of into it
so um
as they did back then
she's like okay i'll marry you what the
hell
you know what the hell else have i got
to do
it's not like she has some like career
she's not gonna go be some high-powered
lawyer somewhere
so yeah so she agrees to marry him
so bluebeard though shortly after they
marry
well i gotta go on a business trip honey
but uh you can look all around my manor
my castle whatever the hell i'll give
you this big ring of keys you can look
wherever you want except
there's this one room
that you can't look in it's this door at
the end of the hall
you can look it anywhere else but don't
look in there
which like i said if you wanted nobody
to look in there then don't say don't
say that
but like i said that's
it's a fairy tale
obviously the woman's gonna be like well
i'm gonna go look at that [ __ ]
he doesn't want me looking there who
knows what kind of [ __ ] up [ __ ] i
would probably do the same thing i'm not
gonna lie i'm gonna get some ice
so
she opens that door
and
no one will be surprised to see that she
finds the uh horrible bloodied heads
either heads or corpses of all of the
ex-wives that have come before her
they were all murdered by her by him by
bluebeard
because they had disobeyed his
sanction against opening that door with
the one with the key
so basically bluebeard comes back in
this version of the story bluebeard
comes back
finds out that
uh you [ __ ] you opened the door i told
you not to and you found all my
victims cause he's a serial killer i
mean come on
and
you're gonna be you're next
but in most versions of the story
uh she has told her brothers ahead of
time
hey i don't really like this dude like
i'll marry him but i still think he's
sketch
so
if you you guys ever hear me screaming
like you guys come running so they do
and they are able to
save her
now
many people believe that bluebeard is
based on maybe a real person
one of the people that they think that
it might be based on was an actual
person and we've done a show about him
uh called gilda ray
encyclopedia britannica refers to him as
history's first serial killer
although the show we did about him it
was a while back but i
i'm pretty sure like a lot of the [ __ ]
about him much like countess bathory
um i'm not saying they weren't terrible
people they probably were but a lot of
the [ __ ] about them may have been
exaggerated after the fact and i think
that gilda rae probably had the same
kind of thing happened although i'm not
saying that he wasn't a piece of [ __ ] he
might have been
but
a lot of the stuff that was said about
him was maybe exaggerated after the fact
gonna say that i don't know i wasn't
there it was a long time ago
now uh so jill duray we'll just get into
a little bit we've done a whole show
about him but
since a lot of people think that he
might be behind the black the the
bluebeard legend
we'll talk about him a little bit
so gilda rae
uh
as they usually are was considered like
a wonderful person at first
we thought he was a nice person at first
and then uh you know he he'd been he was
a veteran man he'd been in the hundred
years war all kind of stuff 1429
uh he accompanied joan of arc into
battle
he was appointed marshall of france that
same year
um
after geneva died though
as far as the stories go
he kind of maybe uh fell in with a bad
crowd maybe
um he was a
uh profligate spender like he had a lot
of money and he would just kind of like
throw it away gambling and whatnot
and um
he was in a lot of debt and started
selling off all of his family
lands
uh and his relatives kind of got pissed
off about it
now apparently
according to legend
as the financial instability began to
mount he decided as one does
that he was going to turn to the
occult now
about this time
1430s we're talking about
um
there were allegedly reports of children
disappearing
from around
this dude's uh castles his estate
in 1437 according to some accounts his
servants were seen disposing of some uh
children's bodies
yeah like i said we've done a show about
jilda ray but i'm just like kind of
summarizing it because that was a while
back and i remember that i remember this
yeah yeah didn't we kind of say this
mother's the iffy case that's what i'm
saying
well anything that happened this long
ago like i said it's just like countess
bathory
did she you know kill 500 virgins and
bathe in their blood
probably not
doubtful i'm not saying she wasn't a
horrible person she very well might have
been but the thing about it is that it
was so long ago and they were ulterior
mode and there were alter ulterior
motives so you don't really know
if
any of that [ __ ] really happened or not
it's really really hard to determine
okay uh let me go ahead and [ __ ]
throw this out there i'm gonna pass the
damn collection plate around if you guys
would like to give jenny a [ __ ] super
chat now would be a time to do that we
don't have a whole lot
left on the show
maybe this is the last story yeah maybe
another half hour
so um if you guys want to go ahead and
[ __ ]
throw a [ __ ] a bone it's about
to about that time and then i can even
get pookie up here to say something
about it pull
you got pookie out here pookie what
about super chats
look at her hiding her face on your face
why are you hiding your face you can
jump down you're on tv
yeah all right so you can go ahead and
go back to it all right
so allegedly a bunch of kids go missing
from around the student's castles
and uh some bodies were disposed of
allegedly
so there was that
uh
he doesn't get any formal accusations
like i said
being that most of the children that
disappeared were from lower class
families and he was obviously a noble
yeah i'm not going to worry about it you
know thank you very much for the super
chat do you know how that goes that was
camp guy he sent ten dollars thank you
very much thank you very much
we're not gonna forget you bob
thank you thank you thank you thank you
thank you
jenny i don't think got a single super
chat today
that was the first one oh ain't that
some poor jimmy
i know yeah i know i'm pitiful
we'll try to make it up on the next show
it's pitiful yeah what's up what you
doing
all right uh so yeah no formal against
but like i said that doesn't mean it
didn't happen
that just means that dude was rich and
the victims were broke ass
and no one gave a [ __ ] about break well
they still don't but they didn't give us
they really didn't give a [ __ ] about
broke-ass people back then yeah
so they're just like ass your poor ass
kids disappeared yeah people coming
there's lots of those people come and go
they're temporary they don't bring money
with them they're just born broke and
then the [ __ ] is [ __ ] [ __ ] happens
then they die poor people yeah
eat it
i kind of feel like that's the attitude
that they well that's kind of how i mean
they still have that right now
but back in the old days it was like
amazing
right they were like there's like back
then they seriously did not give up you
were born because your people were
[ __ ] okay your family was [ __ ] and
you were born where you were born
without any goddamn money so so what are
we going to do with you
that's what that's exactly well
everybody is born because people are
[ __ ] but that's the thing that's the
thinking
thank you mrs evans already thank you
very much give us five dollars thank you
which is one of my that's one of my
favorite uh youtube handles it's a party
party it's an arty party i would like to
know no comments or i would like to go
to our channel thank you
jenny appreciates it i do appreciate it
so
yeah no formal accusations like i said
not surprising
um 1440
uh
apparently
gilda ray kidnapped a priest
probably not the smartest move but okay
um
i don't even know what that [ __ ] was
about but he's just like well you know
[ __ ] happens i got mad and a priest got
kidnapped and uh mistakes were made
so there was that
so he actually for doing that
he actually did get brought to trial
yeah
and he got tried for a bunch of offenses
uh including the murder of over 100
children oh they cared then once one
priest got kidnapped
oh well okay now we'll pers we'll
prosecute him for
these hundred peasant children that
we're kidding yeah now we care about now
look people i'd like to dive into this
and say i'd be real skeptical about
anything that was wrong about this we
did a show about jill duray yeah um i'm
not saying he wasn't a piece of [ __ ] he
might have been yeah but it's the same
thing we did a show about kenneth
bathory too we did a show about hh
holmes for crazy and we're not saying
that like people like that aren't [ __ ]
bags they probably were yeah but all of
the [ __ ] that's attributed them
probably exaggerated you have to
understand them i'm not saying they
didn't do bad [ __ ] i'm just saying that
like they probably didn't do all the
[ __ ] popularly attributed you have to
understand the the mentality of the
honky motherland uh they like
to turn that [ __ ] up to 11 no matter
what you did
so if you kill one person they'd say you
killed 10.
if you did this or that they said it was
just
watch that damn movie demons that we
just reviewed the other day with it was
it called demons that was called demon
what was the name of that movie we
reviewed the devils the devils that's
right devils and you will see how
histrionic they were back then
um they like to amplify what you did
um well people like to do that yeah
people like look people are no different
than they were back then yeah
largely 99 of people in the world their
lives are boring right
so anytime something comes along to like
liven it up
they're all into that [ __ ] yeah so you
want to like make
anything you have to like get like
amplify emotions about stuff you have to
get super outraged about something or
you have to get like super into
something so it's kind of like i'm
always really so you kind of gotta
[ __ ] look at your sideways anytime
anybody says this person killed a
hundred people this person did this on
the other i'm just kind of like well did
they though it might have been four or
five not a hundred did they or maybe not
at all it depended on what [ __ ]
what what was happening i mean nowadays
it's much easier because now we have
like [ __ ] dna and [ __ ] like that we
can actually like determine right
how many people that person killed like
if it's a serial killer whatever back
then they didn't have that no and once
that person was dead yeah all of the
people that like then like legends would
grow up about them and
you know people would repeat the legends
and after a while after 100 years or so
it would become yeah fact right and then
when you have so-called religious
authorities involved they could say
anything
they could say and they did yeah yeah
so it was hard to know what was real
with these people like i said i'm not
saying that like that gilda ray didn't
do all of the [ __ ] that they attributed
to him to him i'm not saying that he may
he he might have i'm just saying that
it's hard to know it's hard to know what
he actually did you're right i'm just
saying that a lot of people think that
gilda rae or at least the legend
surrounding him
uh are a significant influence on the
bluebeard
legend right
now so yeah so he kidnapped the person
he had been something so simple that he
he diddled some kids so they want us
which is not good no but it's probably
the way the thinking of that era is that
he diddled some kids therefore they're
filled with kill 100 of them that was
the way they were like i said and that's
the way they work like i said both those
things are bad right but it's right it's
a matter of degree right you all get
this no one's excusing y'all get the
dream diddling kids right but that
doesn't mean you can't i think he
diddled 100 and then they said
they're both bad but they're not like
equally bad it's a spectrum right it's a
spectrum that's all we're saying that's
what i think kind of happened everything
is nuanced right you gotta like chill
out and like
regard things in that way
dispassionately right
i'm just saying
and i'm not saying but he may have
killed a hundred children how would i
know i think he diddled some kids and
they but i'm just kidding yeah i'm just
saying they blew it out of proportion
because the thing about it
they bring him in like after the whole
priest kidnapping incident which i don't
even know i don't even remember what the
details behind that were we did a show
about him that was a long time ago
so he kidnapped supreme which like i
said
i can't i'm trying to imagine a
situation yeah in which i would kidnap a
priest and then later i could see it if
i was drunk enough it might happen but
then the next day i'd be like what the
[ __ ] was i doing i forgot all about it
here's the weird thing about history
all right you [ __ ] when when you start
diving into these weird stories about
history you find out that they're not as
impressive as you were led to believe
so when you get into a story like this
oh he killed a hundred children
when you actually kind of look at it and
[ __ ] listen to what they're talking
about
and know how the i'm gonna call them the
ancients the way the ancients thought
chances are it's probably like he
diddled some kids
and then they came out and said he
killed a hundred children
because that was they were that's how
they were
and we're not saying that that was a
good dude he was diddling children
but they would amplify [ __ ]
everything you [ __ ] did
he probably diddled some kids
and then uh they and then they came out
and said he killed 200 kids well you
have to think too particularly
particularly back in those days yeah and
humans still have this propensity
nowadays
when bad [ __ ] happens that's nobody's
fault
um
people
naturally look for someone to blame
so
maybe back then
in the 1400s when jill deray was [ __ ]
right
he probably did some bad [ __ ]
but
probably all of the surrounding families
that had like bad [ __ ] happen like their
kid died a plague or their kid or
something yeah they're gonna blame or
they went missing yeah um or something
happened to them that they couldn't
explain
then they're gonna blame it on
the boogie band yeah because that's a
very human thing to do right you like to
have a reason
for why things happen to you
particularly some bad [ __ ] happens
you need to have a reason for that you
need to have somebody to blame you need
to have something you can direct your
rage at yeah you don't like humans are
not good at just being like well
sometimes [ __ ] happens it's nobody's
fault even though a lot of times it is
nobody's fault yeah but humans are bad
at that yeah so it's like if they can
find somebody to blame for that [ __ ]
they absolutely will yeah
so i think that there's a lot of that
going on like i said we're not saying
gilda ray was a good dude
i'm just saying i don't think that he
did i don't think he did with everything
that they well same thing with countess
bathroom i don't think she did
everything she did some of that i think
i think i still think she was like a
shitty person yeah there's something
going on like that but i don't think she
did as much as
well and we talked about this on our hh
home show yeah he was obviously a hero
killer yeah he was a crazy person yeah
did he do everything that was attributed
to him in the media no probably not no i
think that was exactly because even that
castle wasn't but he still sucks
yeah the castle wasn't as cool as they
said it was which meant that they were
that's an exact that's an exaggeration
right
we're not saying it was he wasn't a zero
killer
right
but but all the stuff that was like the
murder castles if he didn't have that
but i don't think it was
the way people i think to think of it
nowadays the first accurate
story we hear about a serial killer in
american history but i think was [ __ ]
[ __ ] albert fish
because our fish talked
but what alberfish said i don't think he
actually did half of what he said and
that's another thing that's not serious
when they're
i mean the pathology of some types of
serial killers
is that
they're fantasists in a lot of ways
certain types of serial killers
fantasies
because
right i mean they've done certain things
he claimed absolutely bit a [ __ ]
mentally deficient
boy's dick off
there's no [ __ ] report of that
he may have but
the chances of that boy not reporting it
ah
and then he claimed he could have
[ __ ] killed a black
little black kid and nobody said
anything i'm not buying that
people talked even back then back then
well and then he killed this kid and
that kid
i think he killed only a fraction of
what he said he ate that little girl
all right oh he absolutely did he
absolutely liked that but he he i think
he only did the big things
the things that they can prove
and and for him i don't think that was
enough so he had to make up all these
other things and when he made up all
these other things he had to come up
with an excuse in his mind of why you
didn't know about those crimes well you
didn't know about that one because it
was a little black kid you didn't know
about that one because it was a [ __ ]
kid you didn't know that one because now
he's making that up he's making that up
well he's trying to magnify his grandeur
yeah that's what he's doing which sounds
messed up to like a normal person
because it is he's he's [ __ ]
projecting they have a different
psychology right he's projecting race to
a regular person he's projecting racism
he's [ __ ] saying well i have to come
up with more people
what would make them not know about it
well [ __ ] people and black people
they wouldn't know about that like
nobody cares nobody cares about them so
i'm going to say a bunch of them it's
kind of true but yeah i wasn't as bad as
he was saying i don't know but yeah
you're not you're not [ __ ]
any little kids back then they would be
looking for you and they would know
about the bodies they would there's no
reports of that
it's just he's trying to come up with
more crimes
that's what he's trying to do well a lot
of people come up with more crimes a
certain type of serial killer yeah
that's kind of their whole that's what
they do and we're not saying that they
it's all fantasy because they actually
act on the ship yeah
but when they're caught
they will
make you embellish yeah they'll
embellish right and so you can't
entirely like trust
exactly that's likely because sometimes
they did some actual [ __ ] they're gonna
be like oh yeah i did this one and that
one and that's yeah i mean look at like
[ __ ] henry lee lucas yeah that's what
i was gonna say he did actually kill
three people i think maybe maybe
one of them robbery
he probably killed three people yeah
but he confessed to what like 60. yeah
every unsolved crime he that [ __ ] would
like confess to it
he was getting rewarded sure emotionally
and getting ice cream that's how they
get attention yeah
those type of people
can't get attention any other way yeah
so they will get attention by saying
yeah i killed and then and then like the
most [ __ ] up
details they can
conjure yeah having to do with what is
yeah i just i i stuck all this stuff up
their butt and i cut up their
head and like i [ __ ] raped their head
and it's like whatever they can think of
right they're gonna like
because everybody wants to hear that and
that will give them attention and that's
what they want in in in the case of fish
fish told what he did he did this [ __ ]
with the little girl that he ate her and
everything i think he did that i think
he embellished that
that account a bit
and when they asked him for more he gave
him more fish would tell you anything
but it had to be something that would
fit the evidence and because there was
no evidence he had to come up with
stories that
he thought would yeah wouldn't have any
evidence honestly i kind of [ __ ] at
this point
right in time in 2020
2022. i kind of feel like the fbi
everybody that investigates that they
know
that serial killers as [ __ ] up and
horrible as they are
they also do have a propensity to
fantasize and to come up with some [ __ ]
that maybe like shit's bleeding over
into like what they really did to what
they imagined that they did
so i think they know better than to take
everything that they say at face value
you really have to have like some [ __ ]
to back that up yeah
you couldn't run around kill black
people and get away with it
back then they had a serial killer that
was doing that what was his name but the
atlanta river the atlanta ripper the
atlanta ripper killed pretty black girls
they were looking for him they never
found him they never found him but they
were looking for him
but he could have been doing that to
wired girls and they had never found
that was what 1920 yeah 1921 i think
black the ripper
he was like jack the ripper but it's a
black dude who
ran around in a damn jack the ripper
outfit which is crazy but that's not
better known it's not better known yeah
we did a show about it a long time
yeah yeah we did a show about a long
time ago it was like jack the ripper and
a lot of people commented it's like holy
[ __ ] we never heard about this and i was
like yeah a lot of people haven't heard
about it now some of the crimes that
they attribute to him i don't think that
he did them because i think there were
some other [ __ ] that was wasn't related
but
[Music]
the stuff that he did was distinctive
enough that i think it was probably the
same dude yeah i coined him black the
ripper
he was the black jack the ripper well he
did the same kind of stuff so he would
like slit throats he would cut hearts
out he would do the same kind of thing
and i think he was emulating jack the
ripper he might have been yeah because
like i said this was he was jack the
river
early 1920s and he was a young black
dude who could jump easily jump a fence
according to witnesses and wearing a
[ __ ] long coat with a [ __ ] big
brown hat [ __ ] would talk to a woman
like don't worry i'm gonna hurt a pretty
girl like you then bam hit her with a
knife
and he liked light-skinned black girls
that's what he was well he targeted
girls that were walking home from work
or school or whatever it was so yeah
yeah and he was tall
he was seen yeah they saw him several
times yeah he's he was seen they'll
never find he's dead now well yeah
that was a long time they'll never catch
him but they were looking for him it's
just that
the state of the art forensics just
could not catch him
you know and he stopped
or disappeared off the radar
but how many they killed you remember
four or five huh it's hard to say
because
i was reading an essay that yeah
there's kind of like some people think
it was maybe like five six seven some
people think it was more like 20
ish yeah um
so it's somewhere between those two
extremes i think
tina said she's never heard of him
yeah look it up the atlanta ripper
there's not like
like 19 like early 1920s yeah
i think yeah or wasn't it or like maybe
20s wasn't it i thought it was 20s but
it might be like early in 1800s but it's
like it's
it's a case that yeah it's a very
similar to jack the ripper
but you don't really hear that much
about it
the witnesses that survived said he was
a tall good-looking
black guy i think they said he was
light-skinned wasn't he
i think although only really one person
saw him okay
and she was attacked she got stabbed by
him but she survived her mom died though
like her mom got killed by him the
victimology was good-looking
light-skinned black girls
that's what yeah coming and going from
coming and going from work in the middle
of the night he wore a long cloak
long
like uh coat
and a large brimmed hat
and after he stabbed one girl
he ran and jumped jumped over a fence in
a single bound
a tall fence
so young and spry
and uh
not well spoken from what he said he had
kind of a
gentlemanly kind of an heir to him from
what i remember
well spoken
and he says don't worry i've never heard
a pretty girl like you
me bam how many steps
yeah she lived though she lived but her
mom got killed yeah her mom was already
dead actually
well she went out looking for her mom
because her mom had gone to the store
and hadn't come back yeah and her
daughter was like where the [ __ ] my
mom so she went to the store and then on
the way back she met this dude
who
kind of got in her way and
he stabbed her yeah off the top of my
head i think he killed four or five
people maybe
but they think it might be as many as 20
or 21 but they're not entirely sure
atlanta because some of those might have
been other jenny parker wrote about him
in one of her books yeah yeah well it's
a serial killer like nobody talks about
it no a long time ago forgotten
a long time ago and and like i said it's
there's still some people that think oh
this wasn't even a serial killer this
was all different perpetrators i don't
buy that no i don't buy that no not one
bit now some of the ones some of the
cases that are roped into the whole
atlanta ripper thing i think were
probably different perpetrators but
some of the cases like the mo was just
so similar
it was very
it's very jack the ripper-esque victory
he was looking for pretty light-skinned
black girls
waitress
types girls that worked in
public and bars and that's
that's what he was looking for
and he considered himself a [ __ ]
upper echelon serial killer and it
seemed like someone that could just
blend into the area because he targeted
people in a particular area that was
african-american at the time and it's
just kind of like nobody really thought
that he looked weird particularly he was
tall he was a tall and fit black guy i
think she said he was
light-skinned also
isn't that right
he was i think i can't really remember
yeah yeah
but yeah and he was i remember the hat
and the cloak the hat and the cloak and
we're talking about
a
[ __ ] jack the ripper
esque
figure an american figure
in
chicago
it wasn't it was atlanta
yeah atlanta
atlanta early 1900s so a southern serial
killer
um but hearkening back
to england is what he's talking about
he's
that's his style
going after
a higher order of woman
he's not going after back in the [ __ ]
white chapel with these old hags
you're talking about a guy who's kind of
like uh
uh oh [ __ ] you know what's his name
going after the pretty girls all the
time uh who's the [ __ ] greatest city
killer of mall [ __ ] uh what's his
name um [ __ ] 1980s i'm not sure who
you're talking about 1980s
dead body yeah
kind of like an
early
ted 1900s ted bundy looked down his nose
at killers that went after ugly girls
you know he just and hookers that was he
was like oh those no
you got to go after the good girls and
that's that's what
the atlanta ripper was about
good girl he seemed to be just mainly
targeting whoever was
around
and which was mainly women that were
going to and from work to work yeah and
and uh according to what i remember you
saying pretty girls
yeah they usually were pretty girls i
mean although it didn't really seem to
matter to him it was just kind of he
seemed like an opportunist okay
um i remember you telling me most of
them were younger and pretty well like i
said they were kind of like going back
with like they were maids or they worked
at
pubs or whatever right but they were
like going back and forth no they're not
hookers no absolutely not i know old
house none of them were right none of
them were prostitutes right they were
just going back and forth to work muslim
worked at restaurants or bars or
they were maids yeah or something like
that and they would go back to my
original thing sure he was going for
pretty girls yeah i thought they were
just walking backwards you told me they
were light-skinned
i don't know i don't remember if that
was the case or not but yeah
because when you when you look at ted
bundy he thought you were a piece of
[ __ ] if you went after ugly girls or
hookers
said you would be a bottom feeder and i
guarantee you
serial killers think of long social
economic echelons and genetic echelons
how pretty your victims are this is a
sexual
orientation a lot of people have a
problem with that this is a sexual
orientation
well it's probably something that a
certain like like i said it's depends on
what their uh pathology is but i do kind
of feel like the classic serial killer
yeah of the ted bundy ilk let's say
um i do kind of feel like they approach
their victims in that way all right they
definitely put them in
classes yeah you know t says there's an
atlanta ripper book added to my there is
yeah it's good thank you and then she
was he killed at least 20 according to
the tsunami yes no one's entirely sure
because they never caught the person
right she said each one was attributed
it occurred earlier on a saturday night
yeah yeah that's right yeah yeah there
was always kind of like a yeah there was
a particular set of circumstances right
that surrounded like that and it was
usually women that were going to and
from work right they would just be like
walking to their house like to work or
whatever and they would encounter this
person right and this person would
usually
uh the mutilations got worse as it went
on
uh much like the jack the ripper once
did
uh in the sense that he usually would
like uh cut their throats he also in a
lot of cases stole their shoes
they're not inter entirely sure he's
watching the shoe fetish like like me
yeah he would like take their shoes
later on right he would also like cut
their throats he he would cut their
throats he would also like hit them with
something like a brick or a rock or
something like that later on he uh one
of the last victims he actually like
took her heart out okay so t based on
what i remember the whole thing i had
him pegged
as young
tall spry
black
kind of like a cross between jack the
ripper and ted bundy he was he was like
a jack the ripper but he had ted bundy's
tastes
he was a younger guy who liked
a woman of a little bit of a higher
quality okay
jack the ripper would go after any old
hag all right this guy was like bundy he
liked
pretty girls who were
more
just regular working girls you know i
mean who had jobs he wasn't into this
hooker thing you know i mean he didn't
he wasn't attracted to that and he was
going around [ __ ] killing him and i
thought it was more like seven that we
had nailed down
four five six seven like i said it's
hard to say because a long time ago i've
seen everything from right i've seen
everything from 7 to 21. okay
because there were so many murders that
were unsolved right from that time
period
uh
that they're not entirely sure and a lot
of them had some similarities yeah so it
could be as benny as 20. yeah it could
be
he was a sick man
he's a sick man but i understand it
though you know what i mean [ __ ] um
he's
not going he's not a bottom feeder as
as what ted bunny would say
ted bunny would have said that [ __ ]
uh the the ripper was a bottom feeder
or the green river killer
yeah that [ __ ] was also a bottom
feeder that was somebody that was going
for easy
prey
ugly hookers that would just get in the
car with anybody that you didn't
these guys are seeing this as if this is
a [ __ ] date
you know what i mean well the weird
thing about it is that serial killers
are sexual orientation apparently have
their own scene yeah
yeah so if you're a serial killer that
only plays that only preys on hookers
like sex workers you're at the bottom
yeah then that's the bottom because it's
like well oh you well you're not cool
enough
anybody can do that yeah which like i
said is [ __ ] up because
a lot of times that's why a lot of sex
workers or people who are runaways or
whatever that's why serial killers
target them because
one i was looking for them necessarily
and it's like those people will get in a
car with you without any question
because they think that you are a client
so
you know so i can see how
this is messed up but there's like a
hierarchy
in serial killers that's like well
somebody like the green river killer
it's like he'd just pick up whoever and
it's just like whoever showed up so he'd
kill them and then he'd go like rape
their dead bodies or whatever and then
ted bundy of all [ __ ] people is gonna
get all judgey about that
even though ted bundy if you remember
kept
severed heads on his mantel
and gave himself [ __ ] with severed
heads
ted bundy is not any better than
the [ __ ] green river killer and it is
almost
darkly hilarious to me that he would
think otherwise
so you know
that's
a weird uh standard to hold yourself to
you know what i mean
oh well you just target those like pros
don't get a car with anybody
i'm much more awesome because i have to
have some game
i have to pick up like
victims that are not prostitutes and i
have to get them into my car and it's
this whole like i get it i get where
they're coming from
but
you're still having sex with severed
heads
and
[Music]
so i'm not entirely sure like how it
said i don't know
why do you think there's like a
hierarchy there you you all suck you all
suck
equally
i'm just i'm coming in i hear you saying
you all suck you all suck equally yeah
well i said it's very rich for ted bundy
yeah
to [ __ ] on
for example the green river killer oh
yeah you just like pick up the
prostitute you have to be like so much
cooler to like pick up somebody that's
not a prostitute and get somebody to get
in your car and i was like uh ted bundy
you're dead now exactly ted bundy you
also have sex with severed heads yeah
that you kept a refrigerator
and you're casting judgment on another
person let's not do that let's not do
that
let's not do that
yeah come on it's true the [ __ ]
are crazy but that's what i'm saying you
also understand that you always see this
you got to put yourself in the in
the position of these crazy
[ __ ] to understand
what it what the world looks like from
their point of view
and from the point of view of the
atlanta ripper
the atlanta ripper sees himself as a
better version of
probably jack the ripper i'm like i'm a
serial killer but i'm also a connoisseur
yeah i'm a connoisseur i got a taste
he's like a hipster seriously that's
what he's saying because chances are
when you look at the victims of jack the
ripper he probably looked a lot like
those women
they're going after
peers
so
he was probably like that those were
hags yeah
so he's like he's going after women who
are like him
or
somebody he could hook up with
instead of screwing him he's murdering
them
that's probably what you're talking
about there
he's
evidently according to the witness the
witnesses survived was a taller
black guy
or light-skinned black guy who had kind
of a genteel voice who seemed to be
pretty uh he said you know
gentlemanly i guess you could say don't
worry baby i would never hurt a girl
like you and him bam hit her with a
[ __ ] back i never trust that
and then evidently in a single bound
actually don't ever trust a dude
and then in a single bound [ __ ] jumps
over a tall fence and his [ __ ] cloak
and [ __ ] and his big old [ __ ]
overcoat with his hat
you're talking about you know like the
shadow
you know
maybe that's maybe that's
like how he fancied himself yeah
although that was like before that
before
yeah that's what he thought he was like
a superhero yeah like a superhero
uh but you're dealing with somebody who
has a [ __ ] up sexuality who um they
think they're special
that's one of the major problems he
can't put the dick on some women for
some reason or another that's not in his
repertoire some kind of sexual problems
he has sexual problems you know like
[ __ ]
where is he
there he is okay get btk in here btk he
needs to like comment on the situation
he needs to comment
so btk comes in come in here dennis yeah
we need your insight into this session
dennis has not like given us his insight
on some [ __ ] well you have to understand
it was a long time ago and
men have always had sexual problems and
that's just obviously
that's what he was into
you know
he'd see these
pretty mixed girls and you know
light-skinned and
he he couldn't get it at the time but
maybe he could do something like this
and
they loved it you know how they are
that's what that's all were they upset
dennis
well they get upset but
they learn to deal with it you know
thank you dennis yeah that was great
dennis would try to rationalize it
somewhere
you go don't they of course they get
upset but
[Laughter]
well they get upset but they have to
understand that they understand that my
needs
are all that matters right in the entire
world right no one else's wants or i'm
sure it's thrilling for everybody have
any
relevance it's thrilling in my world
because in my world
yeah this is my movie y'all are just
living in it
i kind of feel like today
well no i deal with it the main problem
is that like a lot of people like not
just serial killers but a lot of people
that have that kind of like mentality
yeah yeah they feel like they're living
in a movie yeah where they are the star
and everyone else is and you're a
walk-on part or you're just a walkout
party yeah yeah so you're not doing what
they want
so somebody has to like correct that
behavior
you know what i mean that's exactly what
they're thinking well yeah obviously
yeah so
if you look at it
of course they get upset of course they
get upset but it only lasts for a few
minutes and and and you know
they're not real people
it happens and that's how the scene goes
and you know then it's over i mean
sooner or later everyone will conform to
whatever i would like to have that's
that that's exactly what it is that's
yeah
yeah
they don't really think they can't
really think outside of their own no
uh yeah it's that ellipsism
yeah to the maximum big time solipsism
and they are the center of the honestly
i kind of feel like that's like the
source of a lot of problems in the world
is that people don't understand
that other people
have the same
thoughts that they have it's like look i
would also like to live my life without
your interference yeah and you were
doing this [ __ ]
i'm not just a thing to be imposed upon
right by whatever you want
you know what i mean so
the fact that they can't
uh
comprehend that
is
one of the major issues well it's almost
kind of like uh
it's a mental problem
kind of yeah
you hear that dennis yeah yeah whoa yeah
where's dennis
oh
i don't know if i caught a problem i've
never had a problem with it
but you haven't done this dennis has
never had a problem
yeah dennis has never had a problem yeah
he's never probably yeah no
yeah well
this [ __ ] is still alive right we have
to understand
her grass was too long
she broke the whorls
it happened that happened
put him back there with h.j jones we
have one of we have a bobble head of age
i think uh no need for me too was uh aka
ryan sent us that
bite his head jen says tila yeah um so
yeah what were you talking about gilda
ray okay
now
so we were talking about like real
stories behind bluebeard i'm almost done
i promise okay and then we can talk
about whatever you're right
um
yeah so we talked about the whole 100
children thing and then we that's where
we went off the rails we don't know if
that's true or not maybe it's true i
don't know
but
at this distance in time it's impossible
for us to tell but
another person that i kind of feel like
is maybe a closer uh approximation of
maybe where the bluebeard story came
from
was another real guy
and his name was
connomor
the cursed or cursed
which
how epic is that [ __ ] name
right
uh so this is a dude they don't know a
great deal about him because this is
kind of like from the mid sixth century
so like around 5 40
or so
uh he was a ruler brittany at the time
he was a real dude they do have like
records of him and stuff but a lot of
rec a lot of legends about him sprung up
in the interim so they don't know like
how much of it is like fact or not
now
this dude
who was a real dude
he did become known for his
cruelty
and as time went on he kind of got
i guess
legendaryized or whatever into like this
big like uh villain
in uh brittany
now he was a count
and he supposedly
allegedly became king by murdering
his predecessor whose name was jonas
now he ended up marrying jonas's widow
as one does you kill the king then i'm
like hey [ __ ] i'm gonna marry whatever
then i'm gonna take over all your [ __ ]
um
she actually later ran away from him
and sought asylum in the frankish court
with her son who i think was his son
also
now
later on he supposedly came into
conflict with another
count named uh
the first
and
he ended up marrying that count's
daughter whose name was triphene or
triffine i'm not sure how you pronounce
that
his first wife died no one sure how did
he murder her
who knows
she died though
so he marries this
uh other woman
now
no one's entirely sure what happened
here there's a lot of legends about this
now triphene or trip i think it's
trifeine
she ended up dead
as did
the sun that he apparently had with her
who was named tremier
here's where the legend kicks in i don't
know if this any of this [ __ ] really
happened or not now according to the
legend
when tryfeen
got pregnant
with his son
well obviously this part is legend
because she gets pregnant and then she
reportedly was visited by a bunch of
ghosts
and the ghosts were the ex-wives of this
[ __ ] no damn and they said
get the [ __ ] out of here girl because
this is a bad news jeez um
yeah
uh your husband murdered us
and so we couldn't give birth so you
need to get the [ __ ] out of here before
the same [ __ ] happens to you so
fair play to the ghost they they tried
to warn her they did
uh so trifam was like she believed that
[ __ ] she's like oh well [ __ ] okay i
gotta get out of here so she tried to
get out of the castle
but her husband connor moore uh chased
her caught her and
sadly
beheaded her damn
so you know she tried to get away but
she could not
now
again this is a part that's out of that
might have happened
this part's legend though which you'll
know in a second
so the legend goes
that
saint gildas who lived in the area i
don't know what's what does saint guild
is the the saint of i'm not really sure
but he came across her body in the woods
and brought her back to life
so you know convenient stuff
stuck the head back on yeah yeah yeah
okay stuck the head back on
i was like you know go forth i stuck
your head back on it's all fine
uh so then they go back and they
confront conomor at his castle
at which point the walls
fell down on him
serving justice i kind of feel like
that's some [ __ ] where because kanamore
was a real person he was
um there's like a lot of uh he's
a lot of it's in welsh um because i was
kind of looking that up
he was a real guy but they don't don't
know a lot about him
and
he was allegedly a big piece of [ __ ] who
murdered a bunch of his wives they do
know that
but
there's not a lot otherwise it's about
him but for whatever reason like a lot
of because he was such an [ __ ]
a lot of legends arose later about
his asshole-ishness you know what i mean
so it was really like got
legendarized later on
so there was that
um they built a bunch of churches in
this area uh in not in his honor
obviously but in the honor of his
wife trifein
um
also they think that
conor moore might have been a werewolf
there's so there's that there's also
that kind of goes into that legend
now
interestingly
there are a lot of like precedents
though to the blue beard tale
even though they think that it's either
based on conomor or it's based on
uh
gilda rae
but there were some like aspects of the
bluebeard story that were in folklore
prior to that like kind of floating
around
so there was a story from the arabian
nights and it's called the history of
ageeb i guess
now in this story there's a prince
named aki
obviously
and he goes off on a voyage and gets
lost at sea
now he ends up at this castle
he shows up this castle
and there are 10 dudes there
and all the dudes weirdly are blind in
one eye which seems a little suspicious
or weird or whatever
uh there are also 40 hot babes there
so he's not really worried too much
about the one-eyed dudes although he
should have been worried about it that's
kind of the moral of the story
but
uh so the ladies are like hey um here's
this key ring that we have and it has
100 keys on it
you can go into whatever door you want
but there's just one door and it's gold
and absolutely do not open that door
of course what happens you open the door
oh [ __ ] i'm gonna go open that yeah they
told me not to because that's what you
do
so he opens this door and behind the
store there's a gorgeous black horse
he's like oh [ __ ] that i'm gonna i'm
gonna take this [ __ ] horse this is
the best horse ever
so he tries to get on it
but this horse
throws him off
and then swats at him with the tail and
takes one of his eyes out and he's like
ah
he understands like why all those dudes
don't have an eye so this is the first
written as far as i know this is the
first like written uh record of a story
that's like the forbidden door like with
some [ __ ] behind it that like [ __ ] you
up right
now in the 19th century
uh the bluebeard story comes to the
attention of the brothers grim like i
said there had been a bunch of stories
about it circulating most of them based
on children or
you know the conomor or whatever
so they published an adaptation of it in
1812.
the version they published
had to do with a woman
who
is
married off to bluebeard and she's kind
of like thinks he's pretty sketch
and
she thinks that he's so sketchy in fact
that she says to her brothers look um i
gotta marry this dude i'm not happy
about it
uh if you hear some screaming up here
y'all come running because some bad
shit's gonna happen y'all come in and
fix it um
so they actually do end up saving her in
the end because that very thing happens
like he's gonna kill her because she
goes into the room that she's not
supposed to go in and she screams and
the brothers come and like actually save
her from being killed
there is actually another version of the
story called fitcher's bird
and this story is there's a sorcerer
who
kidnaps
the eldest daughter of a country family
who is quite beautiful
and then brings her to the house gives
her an egg
and says you have to carry this egg
around with you all the time
okay
and so she's like okay fair enough
whatever
um
but he also has this thing oh i have
this room you can't ever go in here and
i'll kill you if you do
good you'll die if you go into that room
now of course she's like uh i gotta go
in there i gotta see what's in there
so she opens the door of the room and
drops the egg
and because the egg has all the murder
victims in it the egg gets blood on it
and because he sees the egg and it has
blood on it he knows that she's been
into the room
so it's like well
i'm gonna [ __ ]
kill you then so he so he kills her
and then this story actually kind of
goes further
it's like not only does he kill that
woman
but he's like well now
i don't have a wife anymore so then he
goes and kidnaps her sister
and
brings her back and the same kind of
[ __ ] [ __ ] ensues the sister also kind
of goes with the egg and the blood and
everything like that
um
and then
at that point i kind of feel like
there's a third one where the third
sister comes in and she calls for the
brothers they come and kill the dude and
burn the house down because like i said
fairy tales are very
uh
in threes
it's you know that's a kind of a common
trope
uh there are also some different
versions of the bluebeard legend there's
one called silvernose
uh which
is kind of like a same kind of thing but
like the dude that's supposed to be
bluebeard is actually the devil and
instead of having a blue beard he
actually has a silver
nose i don't know if it's like a like a
metal knife
type situation but yeah like he does the
same thing where
he's like hey i'm going to give you
these keys you can go into all the rooms
in the house but one
um while she's sleeping he puts a rose
in her hair
and when she gets up she's like hey i'm
gonna go into the forbidden room
you know which i i kind of feel like if
it was i wouldn't do that you know what
i mean i'm not that curious
you tell me not to go on i'm not going
to run
you know it's fine i'm not i'm not
really that curious i don't really give
a [ __ ] we have back there but yeah so
everybody in the story does it though so
what happens though in this version in
silver nose
she opens the door
and it's not just like there's murdered
people in there the door is an actual
portal to hell
so there's flames and [ __ ]
so the flames
singed the rose
that the devil silver nose put in her
hair
so when he comes home he knows that
she's opened that door because he sees
like the roses kind of like burned and
[ __ ] so he's like ooh [ __ ] [ __ ] you so
that kind of whole thing happens and
then the same thing happens where like
the young the younger sister has to go
through the same thing and like there's
a whole uh thing of threes so there's
that there's also a story called the
robber bridegroom which actually i've
heard
several times
and this is another one this is very
widespread in european folklore
and this is a story where there's a
young woman
and she's supposed to marry this
rich dude named mr fox he's not an
actual fox that's just his name
um
and she's like well
she's set to marry him but he won't ever
let her go to his house or like see
where he lives
so she gets curious about it so she
actually goes there like on the dl
now when she gets there there's a gate
before the house and all it says on it
is be bold and she's like okay don't
mind if i do
so she goes through the gate
and
then when she gets to the entrance of
the mansion there's also a sign that
says be bold but two times and she's
like okay i'm doing it i'm doing it so
then she goes in and she finds a
staircase
the staircase has a sign that also says
be bold
a couple times but then it says
but not too bold and she's like oh [ __ ]
okay well uh how is this gonna go
so she's like okay well i'm gonna keep
going we'll see we'll see how this ends
so then she gets uh she gets to a door
in the house
and that has a sign that says be bold
couple times but not too bold
unless your heart's blood should run
cold and she's like oh [ __ ] maybe i over
stepped it a little bit at this point
uh so she opens the door
and finds a bunch of
uh dismembered corpses
so you know much like the bluebeard
story
so this is mr fox the dude she's
supposed to marry this is uh all the
women that he's
previously married
and cut up
and kept because that's how you do
so uh she's like oh [ __ ] i'm [ __ ] i'm
opposed
she hears mr fox coming she hides in the
room
and mr fox while she's watching drags in
a new victim
and cuts her all up
and then
he leaves and she's like okay well i
gotta find some proof so she takes a
severed hand sticks in her pocket and
runs the [ __ ] out of there
and then there's a feast where she
because she's supposed to marry this
dude right
and
she like while the feast is going on
like hey we're gonna get married and
she's like [ __ ] bam and she puts the
[ __ ] severed hand down
and then she says look
he's a [ __ ] serial killer she doesn't
say that but like you know
and then the bridal party turns on him
and cuts him into pieces deservedly so
that's the robert bridegroom story now
uh
so yeah so there's that whole uh
situation
now interestingly
as we mentioned earlier i feel like the
earliest versions of bluebeard
were
almost like admonishments to
women
who were
you know given into marriage they didn't
really have any choice about who they
married you know particularly you know
depending on their social class
so they're kind of like well you just
have to like [ __ ] deal with it
if he's you know whatever
but
um
there are some different scholars that
think the whole point of
uh the bluebeard story is not so much
you know curiosity killed the cat or
don't look too much into the past of
whoever it is you're marrying
but a lot of people think that maybe the
point of bluebeard is that no you should
absolutely yeah
question because you know that [ __ ]
might be a [ __ ] zero because even if
you didn't question it he's still a
serial killer that's how i took it even
right in a day when i was a kid yeah
and that's how most modern scholars see
it that was like a warning to women it's
like look even if you didn't question
like if you didn't look behind the door
he still killed all those people right
and you still need to like be [ __ ]
wary yeah you have to know who it is
that you're marrying right because this
might be a really really bad person and
this is kind of coming from an era that
[ __ ] even before an era really
of [ __ ] black widows and [ __ ]
dudes that were killing their wives oh
well we we covered all that [ __ ] for
getting that money and [ __ ]
just because you're marrying this person
that doesn't mean that's a good person
yeah and i kind of feel like that's
maybe more who this is that's what
they're talking about yeah it i don't
think it's so much an admonition to oh
do whatever your husband tells you and
don't ever no
that's not what it means i don't yeah i
don't think that it means i don't think
that it means you maybe back then people
you know people kind of like uh you know
thought of that it is that but it's like
i don't think that it no that's not
demanding no absolutely not you all know
me i'm into mythology and religious
[ __ ] uh mythology and holy scripture
uh or what is considered to be holy
scripture
and um
no the meaning of this story is is
[ __ ]
you better look behind that [ __ ] door
that's what it means you find out yeah
you better you're burying this [ __ ] you
better figure out like what [ __ ]
secrets you got hiding right you don't
want to end up like that right that's
exactly what it means yeah just like
billy groats gruff you know what i mean
don't be [ __ ] talking to those
[ __ ] sleeping underneath the
bridge
those bombs underneath that bridge my
molester [ __ ] you don't know who
this is you know i mean that that's what
all of those all of those [ __ ] uh
grim fairy tales were warnings they're
all based on realities
some of those realities have faded into
the past the cannibalism
warnings
that's not for the united states right
now
but [ __ ]
in europe in the 40s in the eastern
front yeah that was going on
in the 80s in north korea that was going
on
you never can't tell when these stories
[ __ ] pop out of nowhere and become
relevant because it's the human
condition that's what they're talking
about yeah
truth depends upon when and where we're
talking about
you know that's just that's just how it
is
well what i was saying was that when
this story was originally printed by
charles perrault back in the 1700s
he actually added a moral to the end of
it
and this is back in 1760 whatever yeah
the moral was and i quote
curiosity in spite of its appeal often
leads to deep regret
to the displeasure of many a maiden
its enjoyment is short-lived once
satisfied it ceases to exist and always
costs dearly so back in the 1700s as i
said they were
legit
admonishing women
don't look too hard
into the dude that you're forced to
marry even if he's a serial killer just
don't question it yeah whatever he says
yeah
and honestly like modern scholars have
been like absolutely not that that was
not what they were saying they were
saying
ladies
better look [ __ ] watch out yeah yeah
because that dude might be a [ __ ]
psycho right because like i said even if
she hadn't looked he's still a serial
killer those dudes in the seventies
better to know than those dudes in the
1700s are spending it spinning it to
their own cultural more exactly their
time exactly that's not what they meant
because [ __ ] i've read [ __ ]
mythology throughout the era you can go
back to ancient egyptian mythology
uh the way they interpreted it i i know
how they interpreted it it's it's more
along the human baseline
you know which would be like this
this is more along the human baseline
you better look at what what's in that
motherfucker's closet that's what
they're talking about yeah protect
yourself
yeah so that's what it means in modern
parlance i feel like they're not
victimizing the women for being curious
no um
or you know or
chastising them for being curious
they're just like saying yeah you should
absolutely definitely
if if a dude you buried says like
absolutely don't look in here that's
absolutely where you want to look
you have to
go with your child like
reactions to these stories because
that's who they were written for they
weren't written for a high-minded
reaction of oh well don't look it'll be
okay no no no you look and go oh [ __ ]
that never ends because that that's what
that's what the animalistic child never
ends reaction is is like oh [ __ ] he's
evil
yeah like you're marrying this dude yeah
you better know if he's like beheaded
[ __ ]
of course that seems like a very
important thing that you need to find
out about that person and and what i
just told you pretty important that
actually kind of fits all the mythology
throughout the era
it's not high-minded it's always kind of
what your gut gut reaction to to the
story is that's what they're talking
about
they don't reason themselves out of the
lesson that's what i'm getting at they
didn't do that now let's talk about very
briefly before we
wrap up okay that in the 1920s
there was actually a serial killer
who was dubbed bluebeard by the press
yeah and we were talking about this
earlier like how there was a kind of a
lot of dudes like this and a lot of
women like this too
back in this time period that were just
like you know randomly like [ __ ] uh
killing people taking like you know
running ads and [ __ ] like that
so this dude was named james b
watson yeah
uh according to the los angeles times
watson would run
personal ads
uh and then bring in
potential
brides is what he was doing from all
over the country
he had a bunch of different uh aliases
that he would operate under
uh and he had a bunch of different
personal histories sometimes he was a
a federal agent
of course
traveling salesman banker
he had a bunch of different uh personas
that he could slip into
and he would always like run an ad
saying you know he had money and he had
a job and blah blah he was looking for a
wife
now once he got a right who got a
wife uh he would
do some [ __ ] like well he had a bunch of
wives going at one time because i think
one of the uh you know charges against
him was polygamy
but
back then like i said it was easier to
like move around and like change your
identity and stuff and that was
absolutely what he would do so he would
move around he'd run an ad i'm a banker
i have a lot of money i'm looking for a
wife blah blah and then like somebody
would contact him and he'd be like yeah
awesome and then he would marry them and
then he'd be like oh well i have like
business trips that i have to do like
outside of the city
and then he would disappear and then
he'd have like a whole other wife like
in some other city and then he'd be like
murdering people also so there was that
um so he basically operated
pretty much under the radar
until one of the women that he
conned into marrying whose name was
catherine wambacher
she kind of like was like what the [ __ ]
is up with this dude and she got like
kind of suspicious about it
uh so she
the hero
hired a uh private detective
look into this [ __ ] he's up to some
shady [ __ ]
uh so the detective agency follows him
now they eventually like found him and
that like looked through his [ __ ]
and they found like a whole bunch of
different marriage licenses
whole bunch of different love letters to
various different women bunch of like
women's jewelry that he'd stolen from
various women
so he gets arrested on suspicion of
bigamy that was all he was a restaurant
as far as i'm aware
uh and while he was in custody
they found and they were suspecting that
maybe he had murdered some people
while he was in custody they founded
unidentified woman's body
in washington state
now
because
this dumb [ __ ]
thought that oh maybe that was a woman
that he had killed because apparently he
killed somebody that he could have
remembered you remember where they were
yet that he that he confessed to
everything even though ironically that
victim
was not one thing
i mean he killed other people too yeah
i'm not saying that but somebody else
killed that one but he was like so
afraid that it's like oh that was one of
mine you wouldn't um
that he confessed so
he actually uh
did a plea deal with the prosecutor and
said i'll give you a confession
he accepted a life sentence
uh three days after he was arrested
he admitted to killing at least
seven
of his previous wives he had gone from
state to doing the same kind of [ __ ]
he'd run an ad
i'm a banker i'm a federal agent i'm a
whatever yeah and they would come yeah
and he would marry them and then he
would kill them off to him
and nobody caught him
he killed uh seven that he could
remember
so he killed them
and uh you know he would drown them in
the bathtub or he would smother them or
he would like he one of them he killed
with a sledgehammer
um all kind of different things so
they ended up uh
arresting he got convicted
and he was put in san quentin ended up
dying in prison in 1939
but uh yeah so he was known as the real
life bluebeard because he killed at
least seven wives maybe more they're not
entirely seven is enough man um i mean
one is
more than i mean
that's too many
seven is a little excessive is that it
let's say that yeah we got okay so uh
now is the time if you guys want to send
a super chat you can ask any questions
or anything and then uh from here on out
we can just hang out how long have we
been [ __ ] doing the show four hours
and ten minutes okay so we'll be on for
uh a little while depending on [ __ ]
all right i gotta pee though i gotta go
to the restaurant
i'll be here and i will entertain
everybody
and uh i don't know what i'm gonna make
but i'm [ __ ] getting hungry i'm gonna
get down here we've only had a peanut
butter jelly sandwich yeah yeah
i had a peanut butter jelly sandwich at
a bunch of snacks
i
let me let me tell you guys something
that i discovered
i got a bunch of different kind of
maple syrup
i got the little flat
jugs of real maple that came out of them
trees okay and then i also have the
[ __ ] cheap maple syrup that comes in
the damn half gallon container that i
got from sam's for like two dollars a
big old [ __ ] half gallon of that [ __ ]
and what i did today is i made a pot of
coffee
and i
in the bottom of my coffee cup
i poured like three tablespoons or four
tablespoons of that
cheap ancho mama style [ __ ]
um
maple syrup they just called it syrup it
didn't even say maple i think it just
said syrup on it
and then i put some powdered creamer and
poured coffee in there
yeah she was [ __ ] awesome it was
awesome
i didn't realize you could use that as a
sweetener but i've been like
experimenting
with the different kinds of syrups that
i've had i have around the house
and that makes great coffee flavor and
it tasted like
with the creamer and everything it
tasted like um
caramel
it didn't taste like
maple them it tastes like caramel
i'm talking about i put that down maple
syrup
in the cup and what in the coffee
yeah yeah it tastes like caramel
well maple syrup and caramelized
real close real close
i have to say though i was at the dollar
general a while back yeah and i got the
real deal too tea i got them both
but you know for like the cheap coffee
flavoring i just put the [ __ ]
syrup in it
it was good it was good
um
i got like that i think we mentioned
this before i got the international
delights it was like snickers flavor
yeah
and that [ __ ] was pretty [ __ ] good
and honestly it's good because you don't
need that much of it no it's very sweet
um
honestly you don't even really need like
i
we have splenda
but
okay i know this might be weird
but
splenda
tastes weirder to me
than sweet and low
no not for me
um
so i bought yeah i bought a bunch of
like little packets of sweet and low
okay
because to me sweet and low seems like
just regular like sweet like splenda
has like a weird
i don't know it has like a weird like
taste to it that i can't like quite get
behind yeah you know what i'm saying i
have some but i would prefer sweet and
loudest weird it's a great musical tammy
says great show jenny thank you tiva
says uh snickers the snickers one sounds
good yeah the snickers it is coffee
cream it is good and like honestly you
don't need that much and you don't
really need like sweetener and you just
pour it straight into [ __ ] cold ice
cold
i use maybe like a teaspoon yeah i'll
make a pot of coffee and pour it into a
pitcher and just let it go get cold and
then put it in the refrigerator
pour it over ice and then put the
snickers [ __ ] creamer on it and if i
can stir it real quick and just give it
yeah man it's great it is good like that
the stickers is good and what's the
other one that we use is the uh well the
one that you got
no it's caramel
it's caramel macchiato caramel macchiato
yeah cream like i said we usually go to
dollar general and they don't
although we went yesterday and they were
stocking yeah which i haven't seen them
doing that in a long time yeah we went
in there
in the afternoon yeah they get the
office supplies we get that [ __ ] from
next door
and i was kind of like the general store
and they were stocking everything up
because honestly they have stuff yeah
but there's some stuff in there that's
like
not
yeah stocked yeah
tomorrow i'm going to sams
are you
got the [ __ ] freezer in this morning
remember oh that's right yeah yeah the
freezer the new freezer showed up this
morning because our old one is the old
one's done that's broken got it so i'm
gonna get that out of there so we got a
new freezer i'm gonna go in there and
get some meat and stuff that's right i
heard the garage door opening i was like
what the [ __ ] and then i looked at the
window it was like a truck out there
with the little [ __ ] yeah freezer got
delivered okay
so tomorrow will be uh sam's day i'll go
for a run i'll get some more uh
uh
booze
because sam's booze is [ __ ] cheap and
good you should i mean we have a lot of
booze left yeah i'll see if we can
i'll see if they got any uh
frozen shrimp down there
get some seafood kind of yeah seafood
stuff we'll see if we got that and i'll
get some pork and chicken
some
beef is so [ __ ] expensive even in
florida beef is expensive
i was like i don't know man the other
day i was kind of i was the other day i
was like man i really want like a
[ __ ] rare ass [ __ ] and a baked potato
we got a whole bunch of cows just
walking around
[ __ ] cutting just right across you
got i showed you guys i'll show you guys
the chef
we're just gonna go up there like
they're killing the sword i'm
how much you want from one of these cows
and
sometimes these guys will say if you're
local
if you pay a certain amount
you can buy all those cows feed
until they're ready for slaughter
and then slaughter day they'll [ __ ]
slaughter that cow and give you
everything and i got that [ __ ]
freezer downstairs we'll
put that [ __ ] in that in that freezer
and then we'll have a whole bunch of
meat
don't know if i want brains
i don't want all that yeah who's gonna
eat that you're not gonna they'll eat it
they got people that eat that brownies
i i can eat heart
well yeah that's that's about it
as far as internal organs heart
mostly i just want steaks i don't want
the rest of it
[Laughter]
see what everybody's doing
i just want steaks and as rare as
possible trader joe's we got trader
joe's around here we do yeah yeah i
don't think i've ever been to one but
yeah we do have one we do have one it's
probably like about 10 miles i think
it's 10 miles away yeah
it's well when we went to oyster trough
yeah they it's mostly seafood but they
do have one steak i think it's a rib eye
is it not i thought it was a new york
steak wouldn't it is it new york
stripper ribeye i can't remember okay
and i almost kind of wanted that
because i was like
well
i was like well i don't want 14 or 15
bucks i if they had done a thing that
was like a steak and seafood like a surf
and turf i would have got that
but they didn't have that well they had
all those sides
so what you do is you get that stain
well i don't know maybe next time
we'll go up there like i said i was kind
of more in a mood like the other day i
was kind of like man i want a really
rare steak and like just like a baked
potato because i haven't had that in
like forever says don't get [ __ ]
kidneys to smell like p no but i like
liver i have had liver i like it i don't
know fried liver yeah i like it i don't
know you just gotta you gotta get it at
the right you gotta get me at the right
time and i'll i'll eat it they were
serving it to us in the army
i liked it
there's a lot of rabbit up here too i
[ __ ] had a lot of good rabbit i just
don't want to slaughter the rabbit
myself i don't want to know the rabbit
you know what i mean
yeah i don't either yeah i don't really
want to know i don't even really want to
eat the rabbit i have to tell you
rabbits are good they're like chicken
i know but
they're a lot cuter than chickens but
when you get i used to have a pet right
when you get it you don't see the damn
the rabbit-ness of them you know i mean
they're they've been different like i
said if somebody's gonna like kill the
rabbit and give me some meat that
doesn't look like a rabbit anymore you
do then maybe i'd even oh well i'll go
down and get some maybe i'll go get some
but
i'm not gonna have like a little bunny
because if you bring me a bunny rabbit
no i don't know that's all right i'm
gonna just be like i'm gonna adopt it
and have it be friends with pokemon no
it'd be like a leg quarter like a
chicken leg quarter that's what they
look like even so i'm still kind of
weirded out like i said i used to have a
pet rabbit all right so i'm peter says
she can't eat rabbit i'm weirded out
about it
like i'm kind of i don't know yeah i'm
not saying cows aren't cute they are but
if you all have a question or anything
you want to drop it in the [ __ ]
comment section go ahead and drop in the
comment section send it send jenny a
super chat
if not
we'll be checking off here in a few
minutes sometimes i'm so hungry you
hungry
10 14 p.m okay well [ __ ] what do you
want i got all kinds of stuff down what
do you what do you got what do you got i
got uh
i don't know like i remember like
there's that pork
yeah
i have mexican beans and rice i have
[ __ ] tortillas i can make a beans and
rice bean and rice
uh tortilla uh
what do you call it like tacos or
burritos i can make a bean rice burrito
i can make a uh
a pork sandwich
cold pork sandwich with uh on toasted
bread
with uh mayo and uh some other stuff
maybe [ __ ] pickle and [ __ ] and [ __ ]
like that
i can chill like yeah i can make um
like a mexican
pork
beans and rice plate
or bowl
like a super bowl
with
tortillas
i can make um
i don't know what else can i make i mean
oh no no
uh tomato sauce and
and and ramen i can make japa ghetti
i can i can do anything
kind the first three things sounded good
so you want like a mexican type stuff
yeah i guess okay
we're gonna hold on okay um
no i'm kind of laughing okay
phil mcgrim says my partner's parents
used to eat brains with scrambled eggs
yucky yeah my grandma used to eat that
too she actually used to get it in cans
yeah and i was horrified i would look in
the cabinet being like why the [ __ ] can
of brains
yeah well it didn't exist anymore yeah
like
brains in a can yeah brains in a cage
and you mix them with scrambled eggs
yeah
i mean i've never eaten it i'm not
as far you know i i know the food blog
said don't yuck someone else's yum but
that sounds like super like look if
you're gonna eat it i'm not gonna judge
but that sounds like super gross i
remember hearing about that when i was a
kid and i thought this [ __ ] was gross
and it was old school my dad was yeah my
grandma was eating that my dad would be
like oh you had to do that and i never
saw him
i got a can of brains i'm mixing it with
a scramble like it's no baby what does
that taste like because he's and he's
like it's it's good
but then what does it taste like kind of
like potted meat and i was like potted
meat isn't good that's not really a
recommendation right
it's like so it tastes disgusting this
is what you're saying okay
take potted meat and cook it it just
turns into fat there's no meat left over
i mean i mean did you tell them it's
like look there's it's uh there's better
food nowadays you don't really have to
eat that
you could eat stuff that tastes better
my dad would [ __ ] show up when i was
a kid and show up as a mississippi he
choked
he goes hey you want some of this he'd
be pulling out a [ __ ] big old pig's
foot
out of a jar
i remember though it would be sour yeah
the convenience store next to my
grandma's yeah it'd be bright red i was
like
i don't want that he's like these things
are good and he'd be [ __ ] sitting
there eating that damn pig's foot and i
said what i said that's just nasty are
you eating that on a dare yeah
it's a pig pickled pig's foot yeah
and it'd be sitting there on my
grandma's couch and [ __ ] my dad's
sitting next to me [ __ ] watching
david letterman back in like [ __ ]
1986.
[Laughter]
come on man that [ __ ] doesn't smell good
because it's good it's good
well the thing about it it's kind of sad
because i kind of feel like people of
that age yeah they just kind of got used
to eating like shitty ass food
and they never like really
he evolved beyond like eating something
that didn't taste shitty so it was like
they convinced themselves
that that was good listen read what t
says [ __ ] pickles pig's feet in a
huge jar
yeah yeah well we had that like the the
convenience store yeah it was
a 7-eleven and then it was like got it
wasn't it then it got taken over by like
a private pickled eggs
yeah they had like a big jar of pickled
pig's feet and a big jar of pickled eggs
on the counter
there was that yeah so
i kind of i don't know like old people
they got used to like eating shitty ass
food
my dad would take rc cola and pour it in
a [ __ ] glass and then [ __ ] take a
packet a single serving packet of salted
peanuts and pour that [ __ ] into the rc
cola and start fizzing like crazy and
you sit there that's a very big song
[ __ ] drinking it and hear them
crunching those [ __ ] peanuts
and [ __ ] i'm sitting there looking at
him and he gave me the same [ __ ]
thing so i put the peanuts in the
[ __ ]
he goes it's good you know
and there was nothing to it there was
nothing that's what i'm saying
i think a lot of it is just like
nostalgia it was in their minds it was
in there it's nostalgia yeah and they
don't know any better like they've never
eaten anything that tasted better than
that
he's like you don't like that and i said
well it's not bad but there's nothing to
it because i grew up on this
that's what i mean great you know like
there's nothing really like i said i'm
willing to
admit like i'll eat
like you know yesterday like we went to
the dollar store yesterday and you were
like oh ravioli was like a buck for a
can or whatever yeah and i was like look
ravioli like the chef by rd kind in the
can that's pretty good yeah is that
right like if you have to eat that for
lunch or whatever it's not terrible it's
not great but it's not terrible
but i would never argue with anybody
that that was like
good yeah you know what i'm saying
tina's saying yeah the reason why she
said she about to [ __ ]
that [ __ ] up there at the damn [ __ ]
on the counter at the the liquor store
when they buy that yeah pickled pig's
feet yeah and the huge charge of the
liquor store yeah you only know next to
the big jar of dill pickles
yeah exactly we have that at the
convenience store behind my grandma's
house
t you only know about that [ __ ] because
you're black
and black hey i'm white i know about
that well because the black people are
southern you know about it because
you're black and black people are so my
grandma's house in hollywood all the
same [ __ ] we had a convenience store she
had a convenience store right behind her
house yeah
and it was a 7-11 but then it
7-11 like moved away and then it got
taken over by private owners like over
many years
and they brought in the whole pickled
pig's feet boiled eggs
you know dill pickles all that kind of
[ __ ] did the big jars on the [ __ ]
[ __ ] black people were southern and
[ __ ] they left the south after the
civil war is spread everywhere like a
cancer like all the other southern
people like a cancer and [ __ ] that's
what we saw there are we're like
we spread out everywhere yeah we all ate
the same [ __ ] they call it soul food but
no it was just southern food all
southern people ate like that
and um
yeah it did have soul because when
you're poor
you better have some [ __ ] soul or
they're not having flavor and [ __ ]
but you know we also had high cuisine
also
when uh paul perdom came out and [ __ ]
tried to
perfect
cajun cooking and you know [ __ ] all
this [ __ ] not and you know we we had a
good culinary uh
uh [ __ ] history even though it was
not healthy i mean
all that [ __ ] is not healthy a lot of
shit's delicious yeah but some are [ __ ]
is
not is
not nutritious and also
questionably right like not but that's
just not us i mean mexican food is the
same way indian food is the same way uh
the only healthy food i think
that is still i think would be japanese
food is is very healthy um
but they were forced into that if you'd
give them [ __ ] pork and pork grease
they'd be eating that too back in the
day you just didn't know [ __ ] that's bad
for you always kind of tastes better
yeah yeah yeah of course that's one of
the curses
of course that humans adore you're gonna
go to what tastes good you're not gonna
give a [ __ ] it's like why doesn't
healthy food taste like a donut yeah
this is something that like i wondered
back it's like why does it like [ __ ]
raw asparagus or broccoli tastes like a
donut yeah we would be much better off
as a species now tammy says
tom my mom was white born in [ __ ]
philadelphia the same way yeah yeah well
i get the south was like i said it
related to that [ __ ] so somehow because
up up in massachusetts when i lived
there
um they had good food too but a lot of
it was seafood they were [ __ ] big in
the seafood chowder fish chowder
uh
stone breads they they're real good with
certain kinds of bread and beer
um
but they just didn't have they liked
southern food
you and boston had a place called red
bones which was like a [ __ ] hardcore
southern restaurant that was real exotic
for for boston it was in somerville
square
no
not summerville school what was it in
the place davis square i believe is what
was called near
um
near i think it was called davis i think
it was david square that was near um
tufts university it was that stop on the
red line and they had a southern
restaurant there and it was pretty good
it was yankified a little bit it was
slightly yankee
the people that he owned it were yankees
but they did know the recipes they did
pretty good
and it was uh barbecue pulled pork
barbecue hush puppies catfish
uh that beer that kind of stuff
but it wasn't quite
it wasn't authentic it tasted a little
bit too good
real southern food didn't have doesn't
have as much spice in it
uh it's a little more poverty-stricken
um if it's real like like cornbread is
coarse
and dry
it's not
fluffy and light that's not what real
cornbread tastes like it's like a combat
ration and you're [ __ ] starving to
death
that's what real cornbread is like you
put greens on it and drippings you know
to make it taste good
but not yankee cornbread yankee
cornbread tastes good right out he's
like no that's not cornbread
it's still good though it's good but
that's not cornbread real real cornbread
is
coarse
and dry
yeah
but that's that's the thing
but they don't know
yeah yeah that's right
tina's rice goes yankee corporate jiffy
exactly exactly although like i said
that's still pretty that's still pretty
good yeah it does
but that's not it
i know it's not it's not but it's still
good now real quick is coarse
dry doesn't have a whole lot of flavor
to it you got to add things to it you
got to put [ __ ] drippings [ __ ] you
gotta have
[ __ ] pot liquor or [ __ ] you know i
mean you got some kind of moisture
you know uh
vegetables on there you know [ __ ]
collard green drippings and [ __ ] [ __ ]
like that and and then it absorbs the
moisture and the flavor and then you eat
it that way you're popping up crumbling
up cornbread putting it in a bowl and
eating it
and it's got a kind of
crunch when you bite it because it's
gritty
yeah
the recipes are out there it's just that
that's not what they're going to give
you in a yankee restaurant it's just not
going to happen that way
yeah
everybody's talking about pickle chips
pickle chips yeah pickle chips are good
like pickle chips as in pickles that are
cut like chips or
pickles that are or chips that are
pickle flavored yeah i mean either one
of them are good
also
uh can we talk about how awesome fried
pickles are
yeah they're good which oyster trough
has those as a
yeah as an appetizer i didn't get them
but i love [ __ ] fried pickles i got
them at other restaurants yeah
you done
uh well i want to say i'm going to tell
you i'm like i'm i'm going to [ __ ]
tell tila
the
the best
contemporary soul food going right now
that is very
that i know of
look at poke
yeah
she's like pet me please she's like
she's
yeah she's doing it their little butt
sticking over there
best contemporary soul food
that is southern
that you'd like up there in san
francisco as a transplant as a child of
the south that has run away
we know you will come back one day
but you would be
waffles and fried chicken
waffles and fried chicken with the with
with the [ __ ]
with with uh maple syrup on it and
butter
that's about the newest best thing
that i would think chantelle's has a
[ __ ] great version of that real good
makes me want to go get that right now
i was kind of i was thinking about that
i was like maybe we should go this
weekend like to get some fried chicken
chicken and waffles or they're shrimping
their shrimp and grits is like they're
shrubbery
now chantelle make when she makes the
grits it's cheese grits with a slight
cajun seasoning in there
turns out
she's got coconut milk in those grits
she told me that i was like what it's
just yeah coconut milk i'm like man come
over man come over here and [ __ ] coconut
milk in the grass
it's so good yeah they're sherman grits
they're really really good coconut milk
you're only going to see that [ __ ] in
florida that's really good yeah and she
rides a harley too her and her boyfriend
i mean their shrimp grits is amazing
their chicken and waffles is amazing the
chicken waffles is really good chantal
riser harley and she got a little
gorilla
gorilla baby doll
stuffed gorilla on her [ __ ]
passenger seat with a helmet on that a
little bandanna and then she she went to
she went to uh nigeria
for a month and came back remember when
it happened
yeah i remember yeah she went back she
went to africa
i got we have videos of that didn't we
didn't we post videos on the show we got
public videos so i'll [ __ ] show you i
don't remember it was a while back i
think you put them on like [ __ ]
instagram or facebook or something
that's right next to mannequins the club
we go to yeah it's like two doors down
two doors down
and that's in sanford
sanford florida
that's where all what's his name got
shot they make that [ __ ] [ __ ] sound
like it's some kind of bad place on on
on
on the news but outside but no man is a
[ __ ] great place ever but everybody
loves that place what's his name
dude who got shot
yeah yankees came here and [ __ ] made
it
made it seem like it was some kind of
racial thing it was but yeah i don't
think it was i don't remember well they
made it into that it was just dudes
fighting
okay
i must yeah i don't think it was
i think that was just a narrative that
they wanted i think it was a painful
narrative
but um
all right so is there anything else
[ __ ]
it's just you can't drink it coconut
milk and grit sounds good yeah it's
good it's really it is really good
though yeah that please
all right so
are we ready to like sign off you gonna
make some food i'm making some food
cause i'm [ __ ] starving seriously all
i've had today is peanut butter jelly
sandwich yeah and a couple of crackers
she's rolling on her back what
she ran rolled over oh pokey yeah okay
we'll shut it off
she's like yeah
yeah she's a goofball all right so
thanks everybody for dropping by thanks
for super chats
we'll be back on friday evening
for our side track show where we don't
even have to
have the thing where we
pretend that we have a topic yeah we
could just talk about whatever the hell
so hopefully you guys will
hang out with us on friday evening
thanks for hanging out with us this
evening
and we will see you guys on friday
bye